l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur le président
andré chassaigne monsieur le premier
ministre la convention citoyenne pour le
climat a remis son rapport fruit de neuf
mois d'un intense travail
les députés communistes du groupe gdr
tiennent à saluer le travail accompli
les citoyens membres de la convention se
sont mis à l'écouté des experts pour
forger leurs propositions elles forment
un ensemble cohérent pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique contre la
dégradation de l'environnement et dans
un esprit de justice sociale quelles que
soient les appréciations que chacun peut
porter sur ses propositions sur la
tiédeur de certaines d'entre elles sur
leur opportunité sur les enjeux
financiers
ce travail de démocratie participative
nous oblige tous il oblige le
gouvernement
il oblige aussi la représentation
nationale dans toutes ses composantes
il ne suffit pas en effet d'affirmer que
le travail de la convention contribuera
au projet de reconstruction écologique
annoncée par le chef de l'état alors que
nos concitoyens prennent chaque jour
davantage conscience de la catastrophe
écologique qui s'annonce
une catastrophe qui menace l'avenir de
l'humanité
les responsables politiques doivent
avoir ensemble le courage de prolonger
l'élan démocratique
impulsée par la convention citoyenne
voilà pourquoi déterminé acté ce
tournant écologique
nous allons proposer à l'assemblée et à
son président là la création d'une
commission chargée d'examiner les
propositions formulées afin qu'elles
soient discutées avant d'être soumise au
vote des battues un nouveau pour bon
nombre d'entre elles qui l'ont déjà été
dans cette enceinte
notamment notre initiative et qui ont
été balayés par cette majorité
le gouvernement devra prendre sa part de
responsabilité pour que les propositions
de la convention que les travaux du
parlement se traduisent en actions
concrètes et fortes
monsieur le premier ministre y êtes vous
prêts merci monsieur le président la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président chasse elle vous
répond masqué mais franchement
je voudrais d'abord monsieur le
président chassaigne me féliciter de
votre enthousiasme à l'égard d'une
initiative prise par la majorité et par
le gouvernement je vous en remercie très
sincèrement c'est important car l'idée
portée par beaucoup de responsables
politiques ou de responsables
associatifs consistant à dire qu' il
pouvait être utile dans le processus
démocratique que des concitoyens qui
n'ont ni plus de droits que les autres
concitoyens ni moins soit rassemblée de
façon à réfléchir sur la base de données
sur la base d'éléments précis pour
essayer de formuler des propositions
d'indiquer des priorités de se
confronter à la complexité qu'il peut y
avoir à élaborer le cas échéant des
propositions de politiques publiques
cette idée cette démarche au fond
monsieur le président chassaigne cette
expérience n'avait au niveau national
jamais été tenté je me réjouis je vous
le dis que vous soyez en mesure avec
objectivité de dire que cette initiative
voulue par le président de la république
était une bonne initiative vous en
remercie
de cet exercice de cet exercice original
et inédit ont découlé un grand nombre de
propositions ces propositions elles ont
vocation à susciter le débat public
elles ont vocation à être discuté
travaillé peut être modifié peut être
adoptée par les seuls représentants
légitimes dans l'ordre démocratique qui
sont susceptibles de voter la loi les
parlementaires assemblée nationale et
sénat
il n'y aurait rien de pire et vous en
êtes d'accord j'en suis sûr monsieur le
président que 2 s'est laissé aller à une
confusion des esprits et d'imaginer que
des concitoyens qui ont des droits
qu'ils ont des devoirs et qui ont
remarquablement travaillé pourrait se
substituer à des parlementaires qui ont
des droits qu'ils ont des devoirs qui
travail remarquablement et qui ont été
élus il faut donc que ce processus de
réflexion puisse nourrir votre processus
de délibération
c'est ce que nous essayons si ça
fonctionne si je veux dire le débat
public se trouve enrichie par ce
dialogue
alors peut-être sans doute je l'espère
nous pourrons poursuivre sur ce chemin
mais il faut être précis dans ses mots
la convention citoyenne ce n'est pas le
parlement les propositions de la
convention citoyenne
ce ne sont pas les propositions du
gouvernement et le droit notamment le
droit constitutionnel continuent à
s'appliquer et s'appliquera dans toute
sa rigueur
dès lors qu'il n'aura pas été modifié si
nous respectons cette règle simple alors
je suis certain que même ceux qui ne
veulent pas comprendre
il y en a je les entends trouveront dans
cet exercice
un intérêt un intérêt pour sa part le
gouvernement accueille ce débat avec
sérénité et je dois dire avec une forme
de d'entousiasme ce ne sont pas nos
propositions
parfois elles rejoignent des priorités
que nous avons essayé de mettre en
oeuvre parfois elle s'en éloigne
l'intérêt du débat public s'en trouve
renforcée et je suis prêt monsieur le
président chassaigne a discuté de
l'ensemble de ces propositions
ici à l'assemblée nationale après que au
cours dans le courant de la semaine
prochaine
le président de la république aura
indiquée ce qu'il retient de cette
expérience et la façon dont nous pouvons
continuer à avancer je vous remercie
merci monsieur prévu liste la parole est
à monsieur meyer habib
merci monsieur le président avant
d'adresser ma question au premier
ministre puisque le ministre de
l'économie n'est pas là permettez moi
d'avoir une pensée pour claude goasguen
qui était plus qu'un collègue plus qu'un
ami c'était un frère pour moi
dans cette période trouble que travers
la france traverse la france en proie au
communautarisme djihadisme à
l'antisémitisme au racialise maintenant
à l'antisionisme savoie manque son
regard sa présence me manque
terriblement
monsieur le premier ministre l'état
d'urgence a contraint des milliers de
commerçants artisans professions
libérales et très petites entreprises à
cesser leur activité leur chiffre
d'affaires s'est totalement effondré
face au risque d'écroulement économique
le gouvernement réagit vite et fort
l'état a notamment pris en charge le
chômage partiel décidé le report des
impôts et cotisations accorder des prêts
garantis
vous avez aussi imposées aux fonds aux
foncières d'annuler trois mois de loyer
pour les tpe qui ont dû cesser leurs
activités
c'est un premier pas important mais pas
suffisant il restreint tout un trou
béant dans la raquette
l'immense majorité des tpe ne loue pas
des foncières et donc n'a eu aucun à
logements de franchises de loyer il nous
appartient de corriger cette anomalie
est de faire en sorte que chacun prenne
part à l'effort de solidarité nationale
y compris y compris les bailleurs c'est
pourquoi il faut généraliser à tous les
bailleurs se tait ce qui a été obtenu
auprès des frontières pas seulement
réduire ou reporter leur loyer mais
annulée annulé trois mois de loyer
c'est le sens de la résolution que j'ai
déposée le 24 avril co signée par 43
collègues de tous les bords politiques
quasiment j'écris à votre ministre de
l'économie le 5 mai sans réponse à ce
jour
la mesure monsieur le premier ministre
est simple juste concrète à n'impacte
pas les comptes publics
elle est attendu comme une bouffée
d'oxygène par tous les commerçants
monsieur le ministre pour sauver le
petit commerce acceptez-vous de
généraliser par ordonnance à tous les
bailleurs l'annulation de trois mois de
loyer pour les tpe r si le chiffre
d'affaires si la parole est à madame
agnès pannier reina chez secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
des finances
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
habib
permettez moi de saisir votre question
pour effectivement rappelé les
nombreuses accompagnement dont ont fait
preuve les tpe et notamment les tpe
commerçants
ces dernières semaines et ces derniers
mois les commerçants c'est un des
premiers secteurs bénéficiaires de nos
différents plans de soutien et d'urgence
parce qu'ils ont bénéficié à hauteur de
25% au 9 juin deux cent soixante mille
entreprises ont été accompagnées au
titre du fonds de solidarité ce qui
représente 740 millions d'euros dont 500
millions pour les seuls commerçants de
détail ils ont également bénéficié de
400 millions d'euros d'exonérations de
charges sociales ou vont en bénéficier
si vous allez dans ce sens pour le plfr
3 mais je crois avoir entendu sur ces
bancs une certaine homogénéité d'accueil
pour cette mesure et 24 milliards
d'euros de prêts garantis par l'état
ces mesures ont permis de sauver les tpe
les commerçants les artisans de nos
territoires et je veux leur rappeler ici
bien au-delà du seul soutien que nous
avons faits sur les loyers vous avez
raison de mentionner
nous avons pris également des mesures
très tôt pour les loyers puisque nous
avons des le confinement interdit les
pénalités financières et les rupture de
bail et fait en sorte de négocier le
plus en avant possible avec les
foncières avec les bailleurs commerciaux
des reports ou des exonérations de beau
que de loyer mais je veux quand même
rappeler que beaucoup de ces bailleurs
sont des veuves des commerçants qui ont
remis ces baux commerciaux dans les
mains d'autres commerçants que ces
personnes vivent de ces loyers et que
l'on ne peut pas d'un trait de plume les
priver de la salle rémunération à côté
de leurs petites retraites
souvent ce sont des conjoints
collaborateurs qui n'ont pas été
reconnues comme telles alors ne soyons
pas dans la caricature continuant à
accompagner les ppp des tpe continuant à
accompagner les bailleurs commerciaux
madame la ministre
la parole à madame sylvie colmont merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation
il ya les écoliers et collégiens
reprenait le chemin de leur
établissement et le gouvernement a
appelé les parents à avoir confiance
dans l'institution
mais il s'agirait de savoir si l'on va
réellement de même de votre part
monsieur le ministre
car cette reprise se fait sous tension
pour des personnels désabusés par les
injonctions contradictoires et les
consignes changeant voir inapplicable le
tout sur fond de campagne de profs
bashing d'une violence inédite
grandement alimentée par la majorité
peu de mots ont été prononcés par le
président le gouvernement pour rendre
hommage au travail formidable et
responsables qui l'ont menée afin
d'assurer la continuité pédagogique
durant la crise faisant preuve
d'initiative
avec une expertise numérique inégalée
leur propre matériel
faute d'outils opérationnels mis à leur
disposition ils se sont adaptés pour
garder un lien essentiel avec les élèves
et permettre il est bon de le rappeler
l'accueil de 30 mille enfants de
personnel soignant
75 % des parents interrogés ne s'y sont
d'ailleurs pas trompés en leur exprimant
leur reconnaissance comme vous monsieur
le ministre nous faisons le rêve d'une
unité retrouvée autour d'une école de la
réussite et de la justice sociale
mais la nôtre ne se berce pas de mots et
de promesses non tenues les vacances
apprenantes ne permettront pas de
rattraper le retard scolaire des enfants
dès lors que s'annonce pour la rentrée
la multiplication de suppressions de
classes de postes d'enseignants et de
rased
parce que nous estimons la nécessité
d'articuler les différentes phases de la
reprise des vacances estivales de la
rentrée de l'année scolaire 2020-2021
dans une continuité éducative
le parti socialiste a présenté 29
propositions très concrètes destinées à
arrêter d'improviser l'école dans un
système éducatif
miné par des inégalités structurelles à
corriger alors monsieur le ministre au
delà de la communication nous souhaitons
connaître quels moyens financiers
humains et matériels seront débloqués
pour compenser à la rentrée le
décrochage scolaire diot confiné en six
chevaux collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
pour s'exprimer
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les députés madame la
députée sylvie tout le monde en fait je
crois que nous pourrions être d'accord
si vous en avez envie
vous avez vous avez eu la gentillesse de
rappeler la formule j'ai utilisé
récemment la la france entière doit être
uni autour de son école et c'est un
impératif
donc ne cultivons pas de faux clivages
rendre hommage au professeur je les fais
des dizaines de fois depuis le début de
la crise et je le fais bien volontiers
devant la représentation nationale une
nouvelle fois donc nous sommes d'accord
ne cherchez pas à faire semblant d'être
en désaccord sur ce sujet vous créer de
la désunion créole l'union en disant
hommage au professeur de france et oui
ils ont eu 75 % d'approbation des
parents je rappelle sans arrêt cette
statistique est bien entendu je soutiens
les professeurs c'est une des
professions les plus noble qui soit et
c'est au fondement de toutes mes
convictions sur l'éducation
donc oui nous sommes unis sur ce point
ensuite que faisons nous pour préparer
une rentrée qui tiennent compte de ce
qui se passe d'abord vous avez porté un
jugement négatif sur ce qui s'est passé
au cours des derniers mois au titre de
l'éducation
nous avons eu à faire face à des
contraintes hors du commun reconnaissait
le tous les pays d'europe ont eu les
mêmes contraintes et bien je vous invite
à nous comparer aux autres pays
européens
aujourd'hui la france est le pays qui
dès confine le plus scolairement si le
pays où vous avez depuis hier 75 % des
élèves et des collégiens au moins qu'ils
soient rentrés
regardez l'angleterre regardez l'espagne
regardez l'italie et même regardez
l'allemagne et nous en reparlerons
donc soyons unis pour réussir des choses
comme celles là
maintenant comment préparons-nous la
rentrée il y avait les vacances
apprenantes c'est vrai il ya aussi des
préparations de rentrée pour vous dire
l'esprit d'union dans lequel je suis je
vais évidemment regarder vos
propositions
je suis en train de d'avoir lé dialogue
avec les organisations syndicales pour
la préparation de rentrée où il ya des
mêmes moyens supplémentaires
nous en avons même créé pendant le
confinement 1400 postes supplémentaires
en plus des 400 prévues pour le 1er
degré ça n'a jamais été fait par aucun
gouvernement en cours d'année budgétaire
et bien sûr
nous aurons une aide personnalisée pour
chaque enfant en difficulté à la rentrée
nous serons attentifs à chaque enfant
c'est ce qu'à la république c'est ça
l'école et nous devons être unis autour
de ces objectifs
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur françois michel lambert merci
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur premier ministre
après plusieurs mois de travaux la
convention citoyenne pour le climat a
présenté ses 149 propositions et ses 600
pages
elle serait la traduction de la tente
des français pour répondre au défi
climatique
nous saluons ce travail collectif inédit
qui bouscule le fonctionnement classique
de nos institutions
toutefois nous alertons sur le risque
d'une déception immense
si cette démarche n'aboutit pas
si la démocratie représentative les
corps intermédiaires les territoires ne
sont plus les socles de notre démocratie
alors pour retrouver un équilibre entre
démocratie participative et démocratie
représentative
nous vous demandons de livrer sans
filtre les mesures législatives afin de
les soumettre à l'examen et au débat de
la représentation nationale
une partie des propositions devraient
même être soumise dès la semaine
prochaine dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances rectificative
n'attendons pas d'autre proposition
questionne sur des loi à peine votée par
la majorité et qui sont déjà dépassés
par la tente des citoyens je pense à la
loi économie circulaire la loi sur la
mobilité la loi énergie climat tout déjà
dépassé par les attentes des citoyens
je ne peux m'empêcher de vous rappeler
que le groupe liberté territoire apporté
nombre d'amendements qui ont été votées
repoussé parfois avec véhémence voir
ironie par les ministres de votre
majorité
ainsi jeudi dernier jeu présenté un
amendement pour un impôt de solidarité
écologique et économique
repoussé avec hargne par la majorité
finalement cette idée est un des piliers
financiers de la convention pour le
climat monsieur le premier ministre
seriez vous prêt à créer une démarche
participative et collectives intégrant
dorénavant les apports des
parlementaires réellement écologistes et
qui ont des réponses de longue date sur
ces questions ou bien continuerez-vous
à ne croire que dans l'unicité de la
pensée qui serait incarnée par votre
majorité majorité aujourd'hui totalement
discrédité sur l'écologie je vous
remercie
merci monsieur lambert la parole à
madame elisabeth bornes listre de la
transition écologique
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
précieux le député françois michel
lambert moi je pense que le travail
remarquable réalisé par 150 citoyens que
vous avez rappelé mérite mieux que des
polémiques ou de l'instrumentalisation
[Musique]
alors vous voyez quand on voit que 150
citoyens des femmes des hommes âgés de
16 à 82 ans représentant toutes les
catégories socioprofessionnelles venons
de tous les territoires ont pris sur
leur temps personnel pour produire une
vision globale
je pense que ça impose le respect et
vous voyez monsieur le député moi je
suis très heureuse d'avoir eu l'occasion
d'échanger à de nombreuses reprises avec
ses citoyens qui m'ont dit avoir pu
s'appuyer sur les lois fortes que notre
majorité a porté dans ce quinquennat
je pense à la loi d'orientation des
mobilités à la loi anti gaspillage pour
une économie circulaire est la loi
énergie climat nord propositions
rejoignent largement les orientations de
ces projets de loi alors les citoyens
aujourd'hui nous disent qu'ils veulent
aller plus vite ou plus loin m'écouter
moi je me réjouis que l'évolution des
mentalités rendent aujourd'hui possible
des mesures qui n'étaient sans doute pas
mais je pense que c'est aussi important
que le consensus qui a été trouvé au
sein de la convention citoyenne que la
construction de ce consensus poursuivre
maintenant avec l'ensemble des citoyens
soit au parlement soit le cas échéant
par référendum jour merci merci madame
le ministre
la parole est à monsieur ugo bernalicis
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse
dames la ministre de la justice madame
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet
dans la commission denquête que je que
je préside il nous est indiqué que les
remontées d'informations notamment dans
les affaires individuelles sensibles
existent parce que la garde des sceaux
doit pouvoir répondre répondre devant
l'arbre la représentation nationale de
la politique pénale et devant les
députés
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans un
instant l'effet que je vais vous exposer
sont particulièrement troublant d'aucuns
pourraient parler d' affaire d'état le
30 juin dernier
eliane houlette procureur national
financière part à la retraite le 1er
juillet muriel fusina est désigné par la
procureure générale madame champrenault
contre l'avis de madame roulettes pour
faire son intérim contre l'avis de
madame houlette c'est la même madame
champrenault qui est mise en cause dans
le cadre de la sphère fillon pour les
pressions hiérarchiques à la fit subir
un malien moule aliens houlette le même
1er juillet emmanuel macron joint au
dossier alexis kohler une lettre
manuscrite de sa part visant à absoudre
monsieur kohler des chefs d'inculpation
dont il faisait l'objet
dans le dossier msc le 18 juillet le
procès verbaux des policiers le privé de
synthèse et modifié en conséquence
et le 21 août alors que nous sommes
toujours dans la période d'intérim du
parquet national financiers il y à un
classement sans suite alors qu'il n'y a
pas d'urgence dans cette affaire est que
le nouveau procureur n'est pas nommé
madame la garde des sceaux madame la
ministre du fait des remontées
d'informations dans les affaires
sensibles
étiez vous au courant de cela étiez vous
au courant que le président de la
république censé être garant de
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
au titre de l'article 64 de la
constitution et est intervenu
directement dans un dossier individuel
êtes vous prête à ouvrir une enquête de
l'inspection générale de la justice
merci monsieur bernalicis la parole et à
madame nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député bernalicis votre
question englobe plusieurs éléments
auxquels il est très difficile ici de
répondre en quelques minutes
tant la confusion qui résulte des
différents éléments que vous avez amené
prend une réponse claire délicate je
répondrai donc en deux choses très clair
qui font de l'organisation du parquet à
la française deux points extrêmement
clair d'abord premier point
effectivement nous avons un parquet
hiérarchisé pour les instructions de
politique pénale général puisque le
garde des sceaux membres du gouvernement
est responsable devant la représentation
nationale nous sommes responsables
politiquement il est donc logique que la
politique pénale s'applique dans tout le
territoire français et que nous
puissions en ce sens donné des
instructions générales par ailleurs et
c'est le deuxième point de la réponse
que je souhaiterais faire
vous avez évoqué les remontées
d'informations
là encore la loi est extrêmement claire
est l'une de mes prédécesseurs avaient
clairement fixé les choses un certain
nombre de remontées d'informations sont
possibles dans des cas extrêmement
précis qui permettent soit de répondre à
des éléments de communication soit
d'avoir connaissance d'éléments de fait
qui correspondent à une politique
publique que nous voulons nos mais je
pense que vous nous pardon que nous
voulons porter je pense par exemple à la
politique de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes
soit je ne vois pas ce qu'il y'a
d'excitant dans le mot porter ou mener
mais enfin très bien soit également
parce que il est tout à fait important
que nous ayons connaissance d'éléments
par exemple dans le cadre des situations
de violence que nous avons connu à dijon
il était important que je puisse
disposer d'un certain nombre d'éléments
je terminerai simplement en vous disant
monsieur le député que le conseil
constitutionnel comme la cour de justice
de l'union européenne ont reconnu que
ainsi organiser le parquet à la
française répondait aux exigences
d'indépendance et d'impartialité de la
justice m
la ministre monsieur le député hublot
bernalicis mac il avait la parole et
nous seuls ma question était tout à fait
clair elle portait sur la sphère
d'alexis kohler 2ème essai de la
position du parquet général sous votre
autorité de la désignation de l'intérim
de madame eliane houlette vous faites
semblant de ne pas avoir compris ma
question
les françaises et les français en
tireront les conclusions merci monsieur
le député la parole est à monsieur
julien aubert
monsieur le premier ministre
les propos tenus sous serment devant une
commission d enquête parlementaire par
man il ya tout eliane houlette ancien
chef du parquet national financiers ont
choqué l'ensemble de la classe politique
jusqu'à monsieur mélenchon et monsieur
bernalicis vous êtes un homme
suffisamment avertis de la complexité de
cette affaire est suffisamment lucide
sur les dangers qu'elle fait courir à la
république pour ne pas vous investir
personnellement dans la recherche de la
vérité
outre des demandes de transmission
rapide d'actes procéduraux sur l'
enquête concernant françois fillon
madame houlette a fait état d'une
convocation par madame le procureur
général de paris catherine champrenault
pour que l' enquête préliminaire
déclenchée le 25 janvier 2017 laisse la
place à une information judiciaire
permettant la désignation d'un juge
d'instruction
madame houlette a fini par obtempérer et
monsieur serge tournaire a été désigné
le fait que madame champrenault
ancienne conseillère de ségolène royal
était imposé sa ce poste à la surprise
générale par françois hollande jette une
ombre sur une enquête menée au pas de
charge à partir d'un simple article de
journal certaines affaires qui
concernent la majorité sont plutôt géré
par des tortues que des lièvres mais
question ne vise pas à contester le lien
parquet garde des sceaux et encore moins
à trancher sur le fond de la faire mais
portent sur l'impartialité de la justice
premièrement madame champrenault évoque
dans son communiqué un courrier en date
du 17
2010cette réclamant louvain réclamant
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
mais ce courrier est introuvable ceci
viole l'article 36 du code de procédure
pénale qui prévoit que les instructions
écrites procédurales sont versés au
dossier
comment l'expliquez vous deuxièmement
sachant que monsieur urvoas ministre de
la justice a été condamné par la cour de
justice de la république pour avoir
transmis des informations
confidentielles à thierry solère portant
sur une enquête pour fraude fiscale qui
le visaient nous le souhaiterions savoir
à qui exactement les informations
remontées madame champrenault ont été
transmises
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
aubert les propos de l'ancien procureur
république financière devant la
commission denquête de votre assemblée
nationale on a tort ou à raison
distiller le doute sur l'indépendance et
l'impartialité de la justice dans la
conduite de la faire vous évoquez je
sais que votre commission d' enquête
présidée par monsieur bernalicis
procédera à toutes les auditions
nécessaires pour que les réponses aux
interrogations qui se posent soit
formulée le président de la république
est pour sa part le garant de
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
et dans cette mission
il est assisté par le supérieur de la
magistrature il était donc parfaitement
légitime qu'ils sollicitent cette
institution pour donner son appréciation
sur le fonctionnement de la justice dans
cette affaire
il appartiendra au conseil supérieur de
la magistrature de se penser sur
l'exercice du pouvoir hiérarchique tel
qu'il appartient logiquement à la
procureure générale et sur la manière
dont elle l'a exercée je les dis à
l'instant je suis attaché au parquet à
la française je considère qu'il répond à
logique politique je viens de répondre à
la question posée il répond à une
logique politique il répond également à
une organisation particulière qui est
défini par des lois très précises que
nous respectons je le dis et je le
répète devant vous nous pouvons donner
des instructions générales mais nous ne
pouvons pas donné d'instructions je
parle de la garde des sceaux
d'instructions particulières dans des
affaires particulières c'est tout à fait
essentiel le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature dispose des moyens pour
s'assurer que le cadre a été respectée
il pourra notamment entendre les
protagonistes j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
que s'il a besoin de solliciter
l'inspection générale de la justice se
sera également à sa disposition
je pense qu'il est essentiel de lever
tout doute délétère sur leurs
institutions
monsieur aubert le csn n'a aucun pouvoir
d'investigation ni de perquisition il
faut saisir l'inspection monsieur le
premier ministre ne vous cachez pas des
remises de la justice c'est un devoir
moral pour toute la classe politique et
religieux le député
la parole est à monsieur jean-charles
cola roi merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
elisabeth bornes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
madame la ministre les 150 membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat vous
ont transmis leurs propositions ce
dimanche 21 juin à l'issue de neuf mois
intenses de travaux forcés de constater
que le choix audacieux qui avait fait le
président de la république il y à plus
d'un an est aujourd'hui un succès nous
députés de la république en marche
tenons à souligner la réussite de cet
exercice inédit de démocratie
participative
nous tenons également à saluer le
travail et l'engagement des 150 citoyens
depuis trois ans notre majorité a déjà
beaucoup plus vrai en faveur de la
préservation du climat et de la
biodiversité
les fondamentaux sont là pour amplifier
nos efforts et permettre à chaque
français d'être acteurs de la transition
écologique démocratie participative et
démocratie représentative s'enrichissent
et se complètent la conclusion des
travaux de la convention ne doit pas
être n'aboutisse mans mais le début d'un
partenariat exigeant et essentielle
entre parlementaires et citoyens la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
illustre d'ailleurs notre volonté
d'associer plus et mieux les citoyens au
débat démocratique à la prise de
décision et à la mise en oeuvre des
projets
la voie est maintenant ouverte pour
mettre en oeuvre une écologie
progressiste pertinentes sur le plan
économique créatrice d'emplois et
porteuse de sens en particulier pour
notre jeunesse
oui cette écologie représente une triple
opportunité de développement économique
de justice sociale et d'aménagement du
territoire
de plus en plus en lien avec les
collectivités territoriales et avec les
citoyens madame la ministre
pourriez vous nous préciser quelles
seront les prochaines étapes et les
mesures prises par le gouvernement afin
de mettre en oeuvre les propositions de
la convention citoyenne
merci monsieur le député la parole à
madame elisabeth bornes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean charles kohlhaas roi lorsque le
président de la république a lancé la
convention citoyenne convention qui m'a
effectivement remis ses travaux ce week
end beaucoup douté et je voudrais à cet
instant rendre hommage à françois de
rugy qui avait porté cette initiative
alors beaucoup beaucoup se demander si
ces 150 citoyens tirés au sort irait au
bout de leur mission et proposerait des
mesures à la hauteur de l'urgence
climatique
je peux vous le dire monsieur le député
neuf mois après son lancement
cette expérience inédite est d'ores et
déjà un très grand succès alors où on
pointe souvent l'individualisme 150
citoyens ont pris sur leur temps
personnel dans l'intérêt du pays
alors où on déplore un climat de
polémiques permanentes 150 français
venus de tous les horizons ont su
trouver des consensus sur des sujets
particulièrement complexe alors oui le
travail réalisé par la convention est
une bonne nouvelle pour la démocratie et
pour l'écologie et je partage pleinement
la vision d'une transformation
écologique globale portée par la
convention beaucoup de propositions sont
convergentes avec ce que nous portons
depuis le début du quinquennat
d'autres vont créer du débat c'est
normal c'est ce que le président de la
république avait demandé des mesures
fortes
le président de la république recevra
les représentants de la convention
lundi prochain il pourra leur préciser
la suite donnée à leurs travaux les
propositions qui ont pu être finalisés
seront en effet soumise au parlement où
un référendum parce qu'il est essentiel
que la démocratie délibérative
s'articule avec la démocratie
représentative ou direct en tout cas
comme le président de la république l'a
dit nous devons penser une
reconstruction économique écologique et
solidaire
les propositions de la convention sont
au coeur de ce projet merci madame la
ministre
la parole de monsieur antoine savignat
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la garde des sceaux
le 28 décembre 2019 le parlement vote à
l'unanimité la loi visant à agir contre
les violences au sein de la famille le
but aller plus vite plus efficacement
faciliter l'accès au juge et la prise
des ordonnances de protection
le 27 mai 2020 par décret vous mettez à
néant l'ensemble des avancées de ce
texte des livres est enrôlé en 24 heures
la convocation autorisé par le juge
aux affaires familiales est une hérésie
techniques économiques et la certitude
qu'un si les juridictions ne seront pas
encombré par ce type de demandes puisque
à la clé le non respect de cette
impossible délai se voit sanctionnée par
la caducité de la demande l'a déclarée
priorité nationale avéré priorité pour
le parlement se heurte à l'obstruction
de l'institution judiciaire qui met en
oeuvre les moyens pour rendre les
demandes inopérantes
de la même manière et concernant l'accès
au logement rien n'a été fait pour la
mise en place du comité de pilotage
pourtant prévue à l'article 15 de la loi
ni concernant les dispositions de
l'article 18 et de la remise au
parlement dans un délai de trois mois de
la promulgation de la loi d'un rapport
sur la possibilité de la mise en place
d'une application permettant de
centraliser les informations à
disposition des vies des victimes
alors madame la garde des sceaux
priorité ou pas priorité monsieur le
député la parole des gardes de la
justice merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs et le début des
monsieur le député savignat priorité
évidemment priorités qui se traduit
depuis plus de trois ans par la
politique conduite par le gouvernement
et qui a conduit vous le savez monsieur
le député puisque nous en évoquant
souvent ces sujets là qui a conduit au
développement des ordonnances de
protection qui ont doublé en deux ou
trois ans qui sont aujourd'hui délivré
au nombre de 4000 priorités également en
raison du déploiement des téléphones
grave danger j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
devant cette assemblée qu'ils sont
passés en un an de 300 à 1000 téléphone
priorités également avec le
développement du brass et anti
rapprochement qui comme je m'y étais
engagé sera mise en oeuvre à compter du
mois de septembre 2020 est totalement
déployée en mille bras pour 1000
bracelet au mois de décembre
priorité donc c'est mon seul objectif et
c'est ce à quoi je m'attache avec ma
collègue marlène schiappa merci madame
la ministre monsieur 2
on peut s'interroger sur le caractère
prioritaire pour votre gouvernement dans
la mesure où il aura fallu que ce soit
notre groupe et l'air sous là direction
d'aurélien pradié pour ce texte qui
dépose le texte qui a été voté le au
mois de décembre dernier
on peut également s'interroger puisqu'il
aura fallu que 136 députés issus de tous
les bancs de cette assemblée vous
interpelle pour vous demander de
supprimer ce décret du 27 mai qui est
encore une fois une hérésie et une
atteinte aux droits des victimes et pour
obtenir ce jour une réponse nous
expliquant que dans la mesure où il
s'agit de respecter le contradictoire
dans le débat il a fallu et effectuer un
certain nombre de consultations et nous
remettre contradictoires oui certes mais
à la dernière minute un courrier maire
nous importe enfin la réponse à nos
questions si monsieur le début des
malherbistes monsieur présidentielle
débuté sa vigne âges apprécient qu'un
avocat respecte le principe du
contradictoire je vraiment je trouve que
c'est très bien pour un avocat
en tout cas dans le décret auquel vous
faites référence dans le décret auquel
vous faites référence nous avons
effectivement retravailler avec les
associations qui nous avions fait part
des difficultés qu'il y avait à
appliquer les dispositions que nous
avions évoqué aujourd'hui nous avons mis
en place un comité national de
développement des ordonnances de
protection je les réunis ce matin nous
avons obtenu un accord sur la meilleure
manière de procéder pour développer les
ordonnances de protection
la modification du décret dont il est
question par cet après midi au conseil
détails devraient être publiés dans les
prochains jours merci madame la ministre
la parole est à mme marie george buffet
madame la ministre garde des sceaux
frappé humilié le parcours des femmes
victimes de violence conjugale est un
calvaire
comme nombre d'élus je reçois ces femmes
lors de mes permanences
il faut à chaque fois mon après mot
libérer leur parole
rien n'est simple le sentiment de
culpabilité induit par leurs compagnons
et la société la peur de se retrouver
sans ressource avec les enfants la
famille du mari violent vivant dans le
même quartier
tous ces éléments entrave la victime à
chaque fois je les incite à porter
plainte mais son assurance d'une
protection immédiate le courage ne
suffit pas toujours à ces femmes pour
accomplir cette démarche
les associations les accompagnent mais
la loi est nécessaire pour garantir aux
femmes victimes de violence protection
et droits en 2010 la loi dans toutes les
violences faites aux femmes instaurait
une avancée majeure
l'ordonnancé de protection permettant
d'éloigner le conjoint violent la loi
pradier voter en 2019 renforcer ce
dispositif en fixant au juge un délai de
six jours pour prononcer et ordonnance
contre 30 auparavant cet article
répondait à l'exigence de protéger en
urgence la victime ses plus hauts à été
adopté à l'assemblée nationale par tous
les bancs hélas le décret du 27 mai
dernier contre vient l objectif de cette
loi puisque ce décret en juin à la
victime de signifier la date de
l'audience à son agresseur bien huissier
de justice est remise au greffe en dans
un délai de 24 heures
j'apprends que ce délai pourrait être
porté à 48 heures
madame la ministre cette année 44 femmes
sont mortes sous les coups de leur
conjoint face au féminicide l'engagement
de la représentation nationale et du
gouvernement doit être déterminée et
efficace
pouvez-vous nous informer précisément du
contenu du décret rectificatif en lien
avec la loi pradier et de la position
dix associations par rapport à ce
nouveau décret merci merci madame la
députée madame la députée marie-george
buffet nous avons eu l'occasion de
discuter ensemble de ce sujet puisque
vous m'aviez fait part de vos
préoccupations et je vous avais répondu
alors madame la ministre sur deux points
d'abord le fait que je souhaitais
continuer la concertation avec les
associations qui s'étaient émus des
difficultés qui pourraient résulter du
décret tel qu'il avait été écrit c'est
ce qui a été fait plusieurs rencontres
ont eu lieu et ce matin même je le
disais un comité national de pilotage de
l' ordonnance de protection comportant
sous la présidence d'ernestine renaît
des avocats des associations des deux
victimes des magistrats des procureurs
ce comité a précisé les différentes
étapes de ce décret et donc nous avons
nous en avons modifié les conditions
d'une part en assouplissant les délais
pour assigner le défendeur qui seront
désormais de 48 heures en installant une
absence de sanction procès durera le
couperet et surtout la gratuité de la
procédure pour la victime et cela nous
permettra de respecter à la fois les
droits du contradictoire mais surtout ce
qui est ma seule obsession l'efficacité
de la procédure pour les femmes qui sont
victimes de violence c'est vraiment le
seul point sur lequel nous nous
retrouvons permanence le point avec
lequel nous travaillons aussi bien dans
les juridictions qu'avec l'ensemble des
partenaires ce matin ernestine ronai
avait deux mots deux mots sur lesquels
elle insistait c'était le mot
partenariat et le mot égalité sur
l'ensemble du territoire
je crois j'espère je suis certaine que
l'ensemble des dispositions que nous
avons prises nous permettront de
respecter ces deux mots au bénéfice des
femmes victimes de violences et de leurs
enfants et je vous remercie de nous y
avoir aidés madame la ministre
merci monopole de monsieur michel fanget
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre je tiens préalable à vous
remercier pour l'organisation du ségur
de la santé qui je n'en doute pas
trouvera des solutions adaptées aux
attentes légitimes du secteur médical
en ma qualité de médecin cardiologue
j'exerce dans un centre de lutte contre
les cancers
ces centres sont des établissements
d'excellence dont nous devons pérenniser
les actions au service des patients
ils sont le fer de lance de la
cancérologie français
mais il ya un statut hybride privé sans
but lucratif
ils sont défavorisés vis-à-vis du
secteur public
cette situation doit évoluer à l'aune de
l'ambition que nous portons ensemble et
des attentes nées du ségur
j'attire votre attention sur l'urgence
d'agir car la survie de ces structures
en dépend comme celle du leurs
vingt-deux mille salariés
il faut agir à trois niveaux tout
d'abord une revalorisation salariale est
nécessaire dans une perspective d'équité
avec l'hôpital public
l'attractivité du secteur en dépend
porteur d'une mission de service public
et leur faut ensuite un accès équitable
aux aides à l'investissement au
désendettement par une reprise partielle
de leur dette
enfin il est indispensable de rénover la
tarification de l'activité pour
favoriser le dynamisme et la pertinence
des soins sous l'égide des ars lundi
avec les élus
ces centres proposent de copiloter elle
les projets territoriaux en cancérologie
axée sur les parcours de soins des
patients dont il faut renforcer le rôle
dans la dimension institutionnelle et le
choix des parcours ils peuvent être
acteurs d'un grand plan national
intelligence artificielle et cancer et
renforcer les liens avec les universités
pour optimiser l'excellence de la
recherche française en cancérologie
il doit aussi pérenniser des postes de
praticiens hospitalo universitaire via
des conventions biparti avec les
universités monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous assurer que l'élan que
donnera ségur à votre politique
sanitaire se traduira aussi par une
ambition renouvelée dans la lutte contre
le cancer et le soutien à tous ses
acteurs
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
adrien taquet secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre des solidarités et de la
santé merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés oui
merci merci monsieur le député pour
votre question oui merci de de saluer
aussi le travail du gouvernement et dans
le cadre du ségur de la santé j'en
profite pour partager un certain nombre
de chiffres avec vous dire que plus de
100 de réunions de concertation ont été
organisées
depuis plusieurs semaines sous la
présidence de nicole notât plus de 200
contributions ont été reçus au ministère
de la santé que toutes les régions ont
lancé une dynamique de partage
d'expériences dans les territoires parce
que vous le savez nous voulons que ce
ségur soit aussi territorialisée nous
connaissons la spécificité des centres
de lutte contre le cancer 20 centres qui
sont répartis dans 16 régions en france
qui sont à la fois des acteurs du soin
réacteur de recherche de la recherche
des acteurs de l'enseignement et qui
participe ainsi pleinement au service
public hospitalier il participe aussi
ils sont les acteurs de la
transformation du système de santé qui a
cours en ce moment et au delà de du
déploie avec le déploiement pardon d
affirmer en pratique avancée en
cancérologie ou encore le chantier de la
révolution numérique en santé je profite
d'ailleurs de votre question pour saluer
l'action au quotidien et leur rôle
essentiel dans l'accompagnement des
patients je vous confirme que ces
centres sont bien autour de la table
dans le cadre du ségur ils sont
représentés par leur fédération unie
cancer et au sein même du comité de
pilotage du ségur
le chantier vous l'avez dit est
ambitieux je vais pas rappeler ici les
différents piliers de ce segment mais
chouette a indiqué que deux aspects sont
particulièrement remontés lors dès lors
des concertations la prévention et la
réduction des inégalités de santé et la
question du numérique ce sont deux axes
ou laisser lcc ont toute leur place
pour faire écho notamment à ce plan
national intelligence artificielle et
cancer que vous avez cités dans votre
question et je vous confirme que toutes
les propositions que vous mentionnez
sont bien étudiés dans le cadre du ségur
et le ministre a déjà indiqué que les
centres de lutte contre le cancer seront
bien concernés par la reprise de dette
qui est prévu donc oui monsieur le
député l'ambition est totale merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur rémy de lattes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre derrière leur matricule
il y à des femmes et des hommes qui
forment nos forces de l'ordre et de
sécurité intérieure doute ils doutent du
sens de leur mission
quand ils entendent des irresponsables
prenaient leur désarmement quelques
jours avant de devoir intervenir sur des
scènes de guérilla urbaine
face à des armes lourdes il doute de la
reconnaissance de la société
quand ils font l'objet de procès très
injuste en violence en racisme en
inaction forcément généralisée
quand dans le même temps de leur
ministre ils ne reçoivent pas le soutien
spontané ferme et sans ambiguïté qui
doit leur être apportées nous nous
saluons le professionnalisme le sang
froid et l'engagement total des
gendarmes des policiers de leurs états
majors et je le dis comme le député de
dijon des préfère mais aux côtés du
soutien de la représentation nationale
il leur manque aujourd'hui le soutien
sans faille de l'exécutif un soutien qui
doit être moral pourrait pour réaffirmer
toute la noblesse des métiers de la
sécurité intérieure et réaffirmé la
permanence de l'état de droit
un soutien législatif par exemple en
étendant la qualification d' outrage à
toutes les injures et atteinte à leur
dignité même public
un soutien matériel et financier alors
que derrière vos chiffres et vos
discours se trouve encore trop
d'équipements et de véhicules qui à bout
met en danger ceux qui doivent
intervenir sur le terrain monsieur le
premier ministre
le soutien du gouvernement aux forces de
l'ordre ne doit plus faiblir
votre ministre de l'intérieur ne peut
plus faillir
quand allez vous reprendre les choses en
main pour réaffirmer l'état de droit
dans ce pays
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député
merci merci de votre engagement fort
clair net et précis en faveur de nos
forces de l'ordre qui chaque jour chaque
nuit à chaque instant répondent présents
chaque fois qu'ils sont mobilisés et ne
doutez pas monsieur le député qu'ils ont
le soutien total de tous les membres du
gouvernement à commencer par le ministre
l'intérieur parce que depuis 20 mois que
je suis en responsabilité je n'ai jamais
cessé d'être aux côtés des forces de
sécurité intérieure depuis 20 mois
monsieur le député y compris dans
certaines manifestations au cours
desquelles il faisait la tacc il faisait
l'objet d'attaqués extrêmement violent
je n'ai jamais mis de mai à mon soutien
et je ne me suis jamais retrouvé du côté
des manifestants qui les mettaient en
cause l'année dernière jamais monsieur
le député et je crois que cela n'ait pas
partagé par tous ici sur ces bandes
ce qui est essentiel monsieur le député
c'est que ce soutien soit plein et
entier et ce soutien est exigeant aussi
mais doit se traduire dans les faits
quand votre majorité de l'époque
supprimer 12 1500 postes nous engageons
monsieur le député un process de
recrutement de dix mille policiers et
gendarmes supplémentaires
quand monsieur le député à aucun moment
vous n'avez voter les budgets de la
sécurité intérieure alors même que
depuis 2010 est ils ont augmenté de 1
milliard d'euros
parce que justement nous devons à nos
forces de sécurité intérieure de les
mettre à niveau de tous les équipements
dont ils ont besoin mais cet effort
monsieur le député ne suffit pas il nous
faut le poursuivre et je ne doute pas
que nous retrouvions tous ensemble dans
l'accompagnement du livre blanc de la
sécurité intérieure qui doit
effectivement construire cette sécurité
de la confiance entre les français et
leur police mais aussi des moyens
significatifs que nous devons leur
donner pour les défendre sans cesse
comme je le fais chaque jour merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est invendable soit uni
ils étaient deux merci monsieur le
président mais mes chers collègues avant
de commencer cette question qui est
destiné à monsieur le ministre éducation
nationale je voudrais d'abord laissé un
hommage à monsieur jean-françois
cesarini que je remplace comme vous le
savez il a laissé sa place il a laissé
sans mémoire et aujourd'hui je tiens à
lui rendre hommage parce que c'est
important
monsieur le ministre les questions
nationales et la jeunesse dès le début
du confinement tous les outils ont été
envisagées afin de permettre une
continuité de la pédagogie grâce
notamment au numérique
le gouvernement n'a jamais déroger au
principe de l'instruction obligatoire et
celle ci a guidé son action pour
beaucoup d'enfants et de parents
le retour à l'école ne s'est effectuée
physiquement qui hier cette situation
inédite nécessite encore il est vrai des
ajustements protocole sanitaire allégé
mais strict tout est mis en oeuvre pour
s'adapter et favoriser un retour à la
normale pour nos enfants
j'espère avant l'été je salue ainsi
l'engagement de nos enseignants peu tout
le personnel oeuvrant dans nos écoles
mais aussi des parents et des enfants
qui font preuve d'une mobilisation sans
faille de patience et de courage
je crains cependant malgré les outils
mis à disposition et la mobilisation des
enseignants certains enfants et vu le
lien avec l'école coupé perpétuant ainsi
les inégalités voir les creusant pour
pallier ce risque de décrochage
le gouvernement a annoncé la mise en
place des vacances apprenantes elles
seront une première réponse
destiné à ses besoin d'expérience
collective culturelles et sportives
alors en soi de ce lendemain de reprise
je souhaiterais monsieur le ministre
vous interroger sur le premier bilan qui
peut être fait je souhaiterais savoir et
prévoir comment vous pouvez préciser les
modalités des vacances apprenantes enfin
envisagez-vous des dispositifs
complémentaires pour la rentrée 2020 qui
nous l'espérons sera dynamique et dans
un contexte apaisé pour un apprentissage
serein je vous en remercie mme smith
s'ils cherchent avec la parole est à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
soit zitouni d'abord je vais m'associer
à votre hommage à jean françois cesarini
et vous remercier pour cette question
qui est très importante et je pense
qu'il aurait aimé poser une question
comme celle là aussi tant ses
préoccupations sociales étaient
importantes et le sujet est évidemment
important tous les étés c'est celui du
droit aux vacances des enfants et nous
savons que de toute façon nous avons des
progrès à faire sur ce sujet c'est près
d'un quart des enfants en france qui
chaque année ne partent pas en vacances
et sur ce sujet avec gabriella talent
nous avions prévu de toutes les façons
d'être particulièrement volontariste
cette année la crise a donné un accent
particulier à la nécessité de donner de
l'importance à ce droit aux vacances
puisque le risque c'était qu'il y ait
même moins d'enfants qui partent en
vacances
du fait des circonstances il ya des pays
qui annule les colonies de vacances nous
n'avons pas voulu cela
avec l'ensemble des ministres concernés
je pense aux ministres à julien de
normandie en particulier nous avons
travaillé pour proposer ses vacances
apprenantes vacances apprenant ça veut
pas dire qu'on va aller en classe ça
veut dire que les activités vont être
encore plus éducative que d'habitude
dans ce cadre là alors nous visons un
million d'enfants de quelle façon
d'abord au travers du dispositif école
ouverte bien connu mais qui va toucher
400 mille enfants qui va être innovant
parce qu'il va y avoir ce qu'on appelle
les écoles ouvertes buissonnière qui
sont des camps ruraux où les enfants
pourront souvent issus des villes
pourront venir en petit groupe
s'épanouir dans la nature découvrir le
patrimoine
il y aura aussi les colonies apprenantes
ces deux cent cinquante mille enfants
que nous visons qui gratuitement vont
pendant au moins une semaine avoir des
colonies apprenantes c'est à dire des
activités pédagogiques et éducatives ses
activités évidemment ne rattrape pas le
retard scolaire mais permettent tout
simplement de s'épanouir et de se
préparer à la suite
et puis nous avons donc consacrer 200
millions d'euros à l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs et 30 millions d'euros pour
soutenir les accueils de loisirs prévu
par les collectivités locales
tout ceci nous le faisons avec le monde
associatif et les collectivités locales
pour que la france soit uni aussi au
tour soit 12 euros de ce droit aux
vacances de tous les enfants de france
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole de monsieur loïc prud'hommes
monsieur le premier ministre fin 2017 le
président macron promettait la fin de l'
usage du glyphosate dans trois ans tout
le monde le sait désormais à quelques
semaines de cette échéance
cette promesse comme tant d'autres c'est
du flan mais pour le glyphosate ça va
encore plus loin
nous assistons à de sombres manoeuvres
pour nous en coller jusqu'en 2027
en effet la france fait partie des
quatre pays européens choisis pour
réévaluer ce pesticide début 2018 le
gouvernement adresse donc une saisine à
lens s l'agencé nationale de sécurité
sanitaire pour qu'elle lance des études
indépendantes
c'est à ce moment que les embrouilles
commence nomination discrétionnaire sans
appel à candidatures de cinq experts pas
trop virulent sur les pesticides plutôt
que constitution d'un groupe ouvert de
20 experts ces cinq bons génies met un
an à écrire
le cahier des charges qui est censé
définir les critères des études et les
compétences des laboratoires et là c'est
un festival
le cahier des charges est écrit de façon
tellement restrictives que seul un
consortium petit répondre consortium qui
comprend étonnamment trois des cinq
rédacteurs de ce même cahier des charges
il est validé par un comité d'expertisé
scientifique dirigé là aussi par un des
rédacteurs du cahier des charges
monsieur n'est ce là ni l'ansès mettra
cinq mois de plus à le publier
mais ne laissera que deux mois et demi
au coeur de l'été pour répondre à
l'appel à projets pour ses études
d'évaluation de la cancérogénicité du
glyphosate
de plus ce cahier des charges oubli
opportunément les tests sur les
formulations commercial évacuant ainsi
le problème central déco formulant enfin
lens s engage cette attribution hors
marché public pour la bagatelle d'un
million d'euros tout cela sent à plein
nez le conflit d'intérêt voire la
collusion d'intérêts
monsieur le premier ministre quand
allez-vous mettre fin à ces méthodes
opaques au coeur même de l'ansès méthode
qui jettent un discrédit définitif sur
cette agence nationale quand allez-vous
mettre fin à ces manigances qui ont pour
but de faire perdurer les mers agitées
est limité
ils nous envoient dans monsieur didier
guillaume ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
le combat politique ne vous oblige pas
au mensonge à la diffamation et à dire
n'importe quoi
je crois que c'est bien dommage monsieur
le député parce que vous savez en ces
temps troublés
lorsque l'on est responsable politique
on a besoin de mettre de la sérénité
dans le débat et de ne pas enflammer la
société et je pense que vous devriez le
faire alors oui monsieur le député de
président de la république s'est engagé
et la france sortira du glyphosate et
des pesticides tel que nous l'avons
annoncé il n'y a aucun problème mais
vous revenez sur la décision de l'ansès
et de l'appel d'offres qui a été lancé
contrairement à ce que vous dites ce
n'est pas un choix discrétionnaire c'est
un appel d'offres a été lancé par lens s
à deuxièmement effectivement il ya eu
deux réponses
il n'y a pas eu 50 ya eu deux réponses
l'ansès à regarder ces deux réponses
et ce n'est pas un candidat qui a été
retenu mais c'est une équipe multi
pluridisciplinaire qui a été fait qui a
été retenu est ce que nous souhaitons ce
que souhaite le gouvernement
camblanes cesse c'est de faire en sorte
s'appuie sur la rationalité sur la
science pas sur les peurs et de regarder
vraiment ce qu'il en est
monsieur le monsieur le député mais il
faudra vous avez sûrement raison
en posant votre question d'évoquer la
suite quand tenue aujourd'hui que les
appels d'offres sont de plus en plus
pointues quand est une norme de
molécules qu'il faut traiter de moins en
moins d'équipés pluridisciplinaires et
deux consortiums peuvent y répondre
il faudra sûrement faire en sorte que
l'inde 16 et d'autres instituts
indépendants sur lesquels ne faut pas
remettre l'indépendance en cause parce
que si alors on remet en cause
l'indépendance de ces instituts je suis
au regret de vous dire qu'on est plus
dans la rationalité
cela se rapproche de l'obscurantisme et
je sais que ce n'est pas votre volonté
monsieur le député mais froid sûrement
regarder demain comment ces appels
d'offres pour être encore plus
performant
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur richard ramos
monsieur le premier ministre de
nombreuses entreprises du secteur
alimentaire vont bénéficier du soutien
renforcé de l'état je m'en réjouis et
vous félicite
mais malheureusement certains
restaurateurs et certaines entreprises
vont se retrouver à la barre du tribunal
de commerce
pouvez vous monsieur le premier ministre
pour herman a baissé les honoraires des
mandataires judiciaires afin d'augmenter
les possibilités de rebond de nos
entreprises françaises s'agissant des
pénalités logistique imposé par
centaines par certaines enseignes de la
grande distribution alors que le que
8,19 que l'aco vite 19 a perturbé la
production elle continue d'étrangler nos
industries françaises
un exemple une entreprise familiale de
ma circonscription vient de recevoir
près de deux millions de pénalités
logistique par une seule enseigne
du jamais vu dans l'histoire des
relations commerciales quand allons-nous
plafonner les pénalités logistique qui
n'existe pas une crise économique et
sociale est devant nous et va entraîner
une guerre des prix dans la grande
distribution les grandes enseignes et
certaines ont perdu des parts de marché
elles vont donc entamer la guerre des
prix dans les boxes de négociations il
nous faut répondre à cette course aux
prix mortifère à ses prix bas mortifère
nous devons essayer comme nous l'avons
toujours fait avec les ministres depuis
trois ans de l'agriculture pardon
essayer de soutenir nos paysans et nos
pme alors monsieur le premier ministre
nous avons deux ans à vos côtés pour
construire une grande joie de notation
agricoles et alimentaires
merci à vous merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame agnès venir une
ag secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
ramos vous le savez on s'est aussi
engagé sur ces bancs avec la loi et
galim notre objectif est à mes yeux une
meilleure répartition de la valeur entre
les producteurs les transformateurs et
les distributeurs
et c'est dans ce sens que nous avons
travaillé
ces derniers mois et ces dernières
années je veux voir dans la réaction
avait fait nos soeurs qui s'inquiétait
il y a quelques jours encore par un
communiqué de presse sur la remise en
cause de la loi et galine le fait
qu'elle se reconnaît pleinement dans
cette expérimentation qui n'a pas que
qui est pas parfaite mais qui a très
clairement fait bouger les lignes sur
les pénalités logistique à la demande
des ministres de l'économie et des
finances et du ministre de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation nous avons
travaillé avec la commission d'examen
des pratiques commerciales à mettre en
place des demi d 1019 des bonnes
pratiques ces bonnes pratiques elles se
sont diffusées elles ne sont pas
appliquées par tout le monde et donc
j'invite les entreprises qui sont
confrontées à des comportements abusifs
à nous les signaler car la dgccrf
intervient systématiquement quand ils
sont signalés et vous le savez et c'est
les directs qu'il faut également saisir
s'agissant des prix vous avez raison
d'indiquer que l'ensemble des
entreprises de la filière ont été
touchés les agriculteurs et je crois que
le ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation suis chacune des filières
de très près les industriels mais
également les distributeurs et ses
distributeurs doivent également faire
face à une concurrence qui est celle des
plateformes en ligne
alors nous allons réunir avec le
ministre de l'agriculture et
l'alimentation
un comité de suivi des négociations
commerciales nous l'avons annoncé la
semaine dernière lorsque nous avons
réuni l'ensemble des filières sur la
question des stocks d invendus qui sont
aujourd'hui dans les frigos pour aider
le laval de l'agriculture il nous allons
continuer à y travailler
merci 1 le ministre monsieur le député
non la grande distribution nous devons
évidemment la soutenir mais quand l
essor nos pme nos paysans même si elle
est en concurrence
on doit la combattre quand elle tue nos
entreprises françaises je voudrais
également vous dire que nous devons
aujourd'hui faire une grande politique
une grande loi d'orientation
alimentaires et agricoles
aujourd'hui ce que nos confrères nous
nos prédécesseurs ont fait les
étiquettes des labels les aop vont être
dépassés par les applications 20
millions de français achètent par des
applications merci monsieur ramos la
parole à madame me george pau langevin
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre la
transition écologique
je la pose au nom de notre collègue élus
de guadeloupe
hélène vaincu à christophe qui n'a pas
pu nous rejoindre
elle souhaite vous interpellé sur la
situation préoccupante que travers ses
salariés de la centrale energy anti
installé à baie mahault
aujourd'hui même le site sera mise à
l'arrêt
ce soir les vies de plusieurs dizaines
de salariés basculeront dans l'inconnu
dans la précarité et le désarroi à
l'échelle de la guadeloupe
cela constitue un véritable désastre
social bien sûr cette fermeture était
attendue puisqu'elle correspond à
qu'elle correspond à la stratégie
énergétique locale défini par la région
et l'état dans la ppe de guadeloupe
élaboré en 2010 est une fermeture
prévisible donc mais manifestement mal
préparés puisque aucune solution de
reclassement n'est proposée aux salariés
qui auront à subir un licenciement
économique sec
loin de nous sur ces bancs la volonté de
défendre une centrale thermique qui ne
correspond plus en effet au nouveau mode
de production énergétique vertueux et
non polluant pour autant comment
comprendre le ministère dit de
transition écologique et solidaire
n'accompagne pas cette phase de
transition et face et syfy des
conséquences sociales ces fermetures
comment comprendre que les solutions de
reprise et de transformation en central
hydrogène porté par les salariés restés
lettre morte
certains vont jusqu'à avancer que ses
non réponses démontre l'intérêt et
l'appétit de nombreux acteurs dont edf
pour l'espace foncier stratégiques ainsi
libérés je vous laisse le soin d'écarter
ces rumeurs
certains experts jugent aussi que cette
console fermeture aura pour conséquence
directe la réactivation de moteurs
thermiques dans les autres centrales on
marche donc bien sûr la tête sur place
la région reste muette et les services
de l'état ne semble pas en disposition
d'entendre ni les reconversions proposé
ni les revendications de ses salariés
quelles garanties
nice en matière de sauvegarde de
l'emploi ou de reclassement
êtes vous en mesure d'apporter leur
classement des animaux nos députés la
parole à madame elisabeth bornes
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
pau-langevin donc vous m'interrogez sur
la centrale du groupe nrj antilles est
situé à jarry donc comme vous l'avez
rappelé ou comme vous le savez il s'agit
d'une centrale qui fonctionne à 99% au
fioul lourd et à 1% au fioul domestique
les orientations du projet de
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
est en cours de finalisation prévoit
naturellement de sortir des énergies
fossiles
en guadeloupe comme nous souhaitons le
faire dans tous les territoires et je
pense que nos territoires d'outre-mer on
partagera sans doute le fait que nos
territoires d'outre-mer ont vocation à
être des vitrines de la transition
énergétique et écologique
donc dans ce cadre le contrat de cette
centrale fuel arrivant à son terme
comme vous l'imaginez elle n'a pas
vocation à être prolongée et le
développement des énergies renouvelables
qui avancent eux rapidement en
guadeloupe est une bonne nouvelle et
permettra effectivement d'assurer la
réponse aux besoins en approvisionnement
électrique de ville bien évidemment bien
évidemment comme dans toute transition
écologique dans toute transition
énergétique et nous l'évoquions encore
ce matin autour du président de la
république et du premier ministre
naturellement ces transitions doivent
être accompagnés vous savez ça fait vous
savez monsieur le député si madame le
député m'avait donné sa question
peut-être que j'aurais eu des éléments
de réponses plus précises à lui apporter
sur l'état d'avancement sur l'état
d'avancement des discussions sur l'état
d'avancement des discussions
qui se déroule depuis deux mois sur
l'état d'avancement des discussions qui
se déroulent depuis des mois mais dont
je suis incapable aujourd'hui de vous
apporter le détail de vous apporter le
détail en tout cas je peux vous assurer
que le préfet est mandatée pour
accompagner ses salariés comme nous
souhaitons accompagner tous les salariés
dans la transition énergétique et que le
j mr sim et a coûté je note que les
masques n'ont pas d'effets bâillon sur
les plus brillants d'entre nous la
parole est à monsieur laurent saint
martin monsieur le président la question
s'adresse secrétaire d'état en charge
des transports jean baptiste jebbari
monsieur le ministre où qu'ils résident
sur notre territoire national ce n'est
pas aux usagers des transports publics
de régler la note du coc vie 19
c'est un fait la pandémie et les mesures
adoptées utiles pour protéger les
français durant le confinement ont causé
une forte chute de ressources qui
financent d'ordinaire les transports
publics
alors suite au travail remarquable de
notre collègue jean rené cazeneuve
le troisième projet de loi de finances
rectificative que nous allons examiner
dans quelques minutes en commission
propose un effort massif de l'état en
faveur des collectivités territoriales
est donc également envers les autorités
organisatrices de mobilité c'est un
soutien inédit
il permet de compenser les pertes de
recettes fiscales dont le versement
mobilité aujourd'hui la situation
financière d'ile-de-france mobilité
s'avère critique
moi je n'entrerai pas dans une bataille
de chiffres mais je tiens à rejoindre la
présidente d'ile-de-france mobilité
quand elle dit que les transports ne
sont pas un sujet politique mais
d'intérêt général et en tant qu'élu du
val de marne et avec mes collègues
franciliens de la majorité nous refusons
toute solution qui conduirait à
augmenter le prix du pass navigo le
porte monnaie des usagers ne saurait
être la variable d'ajustement c'est
pourquoi nous proposerons par voie
d'amendements que l'état compense
ile-de-france mobilité au même titre que
les autres à om via un acompte de 425
millions d'euros qui permettra à parer à
l'urgence et ce dès la promulgation de
la loi si notre amendement est adopté
les transports franciliens pourront
continuer
à circuler normalement dans les mois qui
viennent sans qu'il soit nécessaire
d'augmenter leurs tarifs
procédant par étapes évaluons à l'issue
de cette crise les pertes définitives
d'idées fm enfin si la compétence reste
évidemment régionales nous sommes
garants de la bonne gestion des deniers
publics
aussi ce moment permettra-t-il de
comprendre la nouvelle stratégie
d'investissement et la soutenabilité
financière d'ile-de-france mobilité pour
les prochaines années au regard
notamment du dernier rapport de la
chambre régionale des comptes monsieur
le ministre pouvez vous confirmer que le
gouvernement est bien disposée à
accompagner ile de france la victoire
est à monsieur jean baptiste djebbari
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs et député monsieur le député
cher laurent saint martin merci pour
cette question vous avez très clairement
exposé les impacts sur les ressources
des collectivités et des autorités
organisatrices de la mobilité des effets
des suites du de l'acolyte 19 les
moindres recettes sont essentiellement
de deux ordres vous l'avez dit les
pertes du versement mobilité et les
pertes de recettes tarifaires et chaque
sujet mérite d'être traitée de façon
spécifique
s'agissant du versement mobilité vous
aurez noté que des acomptes ont pu être
fournies délivré pour les mois d'avril
et de mai suite à l'intervention de
l'état auprès de l'acoss et les travaux
se sont poursuivis vous avez cité les
travaux de votre collègue jean rené
cazeneuve qui ont été très utiles pour
construire un dispositif qui vis qui
vise pardon à compenser les différentes
perte de recettes du bloc communal dont
le versement mobilité c'est ce
dispositif qui a été inscrit au projet
de loi finances rectificatif numéro 3 et
le montant nécessaire c'est à dire
environ 500 millions d'euros sera alloué
aux collectivités concernées
s'agissant des pertes de recettes
tarifaires un point précis devrait être
réalisée courant du second semestre en
lien avec les albums concernés quand
nous aurons une vision plus précise de
la dynamique de reprise de la reprise
pardon du trafic s'agissant plus
spécifiquement l'ile-de-france mobilité
je veux d'abord saluer votre engagement
et votre action
l'amendement que vous proposez et qui
prévoit 425 millions de subvention
exceptionnelle pour l'om recevra le
plein soutien
du gouvernement ce montant je le
rappelle ici a été calculée selon le
même dispositif qui a été employé à
l'égard des autres ah ouais mais
collectivités il permettra dès
l'adoption de la loi de finances
rectificative à et de france mobilité de
poursuivre ses versements à la ratp et à
la sncf et une clause de revoyure
imploré voyons est prévue d'ici à la fin
de l'année l etat ajustera le cas
échéant son versement en 2021 monsieur
rapporteur général état poursuit sa
politique en faveur des transports du
quotidien et je vous confirme que
partout en france et transpirer positifs
continuant à rouler les semaines qui
viennent les mois qui viennent ainsi du
ministre
la parole est à monsieur pierre
dharréville monsieur le président vous
venez d'annoncer les résultats de la 24e
édition du parlement des enfants
les enfants de la classe de madame
collin dans l'école canto perdrix 2 à
martigues les ans accueillis vous
l'imaginez avec les cris de joie hier
lors d'une cérémonie où j'ai pu vous
représentez ainsi que la présidente du
jury notre collègue florence ce probant
dié et toute notre assemblée avec un
bonheur profond une grande fierté
je voudrais à nouveau les féliciter ici
pour leur engagement citoyen et leur si
belle manière de parler d'égalité de
nous parler d'égalité notamment
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
les enfants les filles et les garçons
peuvent beaucoup aidé la société a
changé
elle doit nous importer la parole des
enfants madame la ministre des sports la
proposition de loi qui l'ont écrite
ensemble
après de nombreux débats passionnants et
qui a été choisi par les autres enfants
portent sur l'égalité donc dans le sport
il est elle propose quatre choses je les
cite les sportives doivent être payés
autant que les sportifs où l'écart entre
les salaires diminuer lors des
compétitions officielles les sportifs
doivent jouer sur les mêmes
installations que les sportifs et non
sur des stades moins bien aménagé au
moins prestigieux la télévision doit
retransmettre autant de compétitions
sportives officielles féminine que
masculine
il doit y avoir des équipes mixtes dans
toutes les disciplines sportives qui le
permettent
ces propositions sont à plantes pour
l'ensemble de la société nous
connaissons la force du sport qui porte
toute une culture et qui peut être un
formidable moyen d'émancipation
madame la ministre comment réagissez
vous à ces propositions que pouvez-vous
répondre aux enfants à l'heure où la
crise voit des clubs parfois piocher
dans la part des femmes
quelles sont les actions entreprises
pour l'égalité dans le sport
merci chers collègues et parents le kava
dames roxana maracineanu ministre des
sports monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés je suis ravi de
pouvoir parler de sport devant cette
assemblée nationale quasiment plein en
ce jour du 23 juin journée
internationale des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
je voulais remercier ces jeunes de cette
classe de votre territoire qui veulent
contribuer à la loi comme nous voulons
tous ici je pense dans cette assemblée
nationale avoir une loi sport et société
avant la fin du quinquennat
j'ai la joie de vous annoncer que sur le
bureau du premier ministre il y aura une
proposition de loi avant de la fin de la
semaine avec un certain nombre
d'articles qui reprend justement ces
articles
ces propositions sur l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes d'abord une égalité
dans les instances dirigeantes
aujourd'hui elle est de 40% présence de
femmes obligatoire dans les instances
nationales nous voulons la poussée
jusqu'à une parité complète au niveau
national mais aussi dans les comités
régionaux et départementaux
nous voulons agir effectivement pour le
sport au féminin de différentes manières
travailler sur cette émergence des
femmes à des postes à responsabilités
pour leur faciliter aussi l'accès au
sport aux femmes aux jeunes filles sur
le lieu de travail car on sait que c'est
difficile pour les femmes de concilier
vie professionnelle et vie familiale
donc autant mutualiser les moyens
trouver des solutions pour proposer des
horaires des prestations aménager des
modes de garde pour les enfants pour que
les femmes puissent plus et mieux
pratiquer arrivé aussi à collaborer au
plus près avec jean michel blanquer pour
inscrire les compétences fondamentales
motrice dans le quotidien des enfants
dès la maternelle dès l'école primaire
c'est âge où les filles sont encore à
égalité avec les garçons dans la
pratique devant la pratique sportive et
enfin les femmes peuvent compter sur moi
pour combattre les discriminations les
violences et tout ce qui peut freiner la
venue des femmes dans les clubs sportifs
nous y travaillons pour la protection de
l'enfance avec adrien de traquer pour la
protection des femmes et contre les
violences avec marlène schiappa
maintenant depuis le début de ma
présence à la tête de ce ministère
c'est vrai que favoriser l'accueil des
grandes compétitions féminines et la
visibilité à la télévision c'est une
chose mais dans cette crise sanitaire
nous devons aller plus loin et faire du
sport un droit fondamental pour toutes
et tous madame la ministre
la parole à monsieur thomas gaccio merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances nous ne gagnerons ni la
bataille économique ni la bataille
sanitaires si nous ne gagnons pas la
bataille industrielle
ces mots sont ceux du président de la
république que j'ai accueilli mardi
dernier dans ma circonscription à marcy
l'étoile
ce déplacement fut l'occasion d'annoncés
fortes pour la reconquête de notre
souveraineté sanitaires en effet si la
france reste une grande nation
industrielle dans le domaine médical
avec 450 mille emplois et 90 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires des
vulnérabilités sont apparus en matière
d'approvisionnement
man en médicaments et en dispositifs
médicaux par exemple 60 à 80 % des
matières actives à usage pharmaceutique
sont aujourd'hui fabriqués en dehors de
l'union européenne c'était uniquement
20% il ya trente ans le paracétamol
symbolise à lui-même cette évolution
puisqu'il n'existe aucune production de
son principe actif en europe
cette dépendance nous soumet à une
double menace la menace du marché en cas
de demande accrue au niveau mondial mais
aussi la de la menace de compétiteurs
stratégiques qui pourraient exploiter
cette dépendance comme un levier de
pression dans un monde où le rapport de
force redevient la norme non l'avenir de
la france n'est pas de produire moins
c'est au contraire par la volonté et
l'ambition industrielle que nous
bâtirons notre avenir notamment dans les
secteurs où notre souveraineté n'est pas
négociable
c'est pourquoi je me réjouis de
l'annoncé mardi dernier par le président
de la république de la mise en place
d'un mécanisme de planification de la
production française dans le domaine de
la santé ainsi que d'une enveloppe de
200 millions d'euros pour cofinancer des
infrastructures de production
je salue également les investissements
annoncés par sanofi d'un montant de 600
millions d'euros pour implanter
notamment dans le rhône un site ultra
modernes de production de vaccins il
permettra à notre pays de rester au
meilleur niveau mondial en la matière
madame la ministre suite aux annonces du
président vous avez présenté jeudi
dernier avec le ministre de la santé un
plan d'action pouvez vous nous faire
part des grandes lignes de ce plan
d'action quel jalons vous fixez-vous
dans les prochaines années pour évaluer
de la russie le succès j'ai vomi la
parole à madame agnès pannier secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés mais chez le député gars si
lourd merci de mettre en lumière tout le
travail qui a été accompli ces dernières
années au profit de l'industrie car
l'enjeu n'est pas de produire moi c'est
de produire mieux produire mieux sur
notre territoire avec des conditions
environnementales et que des conditions
sociales qui nous permette derrière de
mieux consommer de mieux soigner et
c'est l'un des enjeux de nos industries
de santé car d'où venons nous vous
l'avez dit nous avons perdu entre 2 me
8 et 2018 la moitié de notre part de
marché en matière d'industrie de santé
cela signifie que nous avons été
construits que nous avons été confrontés
ces derniers mois à des pénuries avant
même le coville 19 et c'est pour cela
que nous avons engagé une politique
extrêmement ambitieuse de réimplantation
de relocalisation de sites de santé en
france qui a permis cette annonce
importante de sanofi dans le domaine des
vaccins
c'est une annonce sur lequel nous
travaillons depuis plusieurs mois et qui
a été accélérée par le cos vie 19 et
nous allons poursuivre cette action sous
l'égide du président de la république et
du premier ministre
au travers du comité stratégique des
industries de santé alors 200 millions
d'euros qui sont d'ores et déjà dégagé
81 millions pour accompagner avec
frédéric vidal des projets de recherche
directement orientée autour de la lutte
contre le coc vide 120 millions d'euros
pour accompagner la relocalisation d'un
certain nombre de molécules et on a
notamment cité le paracétamol et nous
nous sommes donnés trois ans avec ses
coince avec ubp ça et avec sanofi pour
délivrer cette promesse de
réimplantation d'un site de production
du principe actif du paracétamol nous
allons également poursuivre au travers
de la politique européenne puisque nous
voulons lancer avec nos homologues un
grand ipc eu l'équivalent du projet
batteries électriques
mais dans sa version produits de santé
car c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons
réellement défendre notre souveraineté
en domaine de santé industriels la
parole de monsieur marc le fur
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
je voulais l'interpellé aujourd'hui sur
une situation très pénible pour toute
une profession
celles des auto écoles est très pénible
pour toute une génération celle des
jeunes qui aspirent à disposer du permis
de conduire pendant trois mois il n'a
pas été possible de passer le permis de
conduire on peut le comprendre du fait
de la pandémie mais désormais tous ces
jeunes sont là en attente pour passer
les épreuves de conduite
or d'après ce qui me remonte les auto
écoles ne disposent que de la moitié
voire du tiers
places qui sont habituellement alloué
cela veut dire qu'on ne peut pas
répondre à l'ensemble des demandes
la liste d'attentes s'allongent ça veut
dire qu'un jeune qui tapent à la porte
aujourd'hui ne se voit même pas proposé
deux dates pas plus qu'un jeune qui a
échoué aux épreuves
la première fois il convenait d'être
très réactif vous ne l'avez pas hésité
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement dès le début avril on
pouvait anticiper sur cette difficulté
or à ma connaissance au niveau national
à ce jour rien n'a été fait en termes
d'heures supplémentaires en termes de
renforts en termes de transfert de
collaborateurs aujourd'hui affecté à des
tâches de bureau qui pourrait venir
accompagner les personnes qui font
passer le permis de conduire
le permis de conduire surtout pour les
jeunes ruraux les jeunes des villes
moyennes
c'est la condition pour pouvoir
travailler cet été ne serait-ce que pour
financer leurs études c'est digne ligne
de plus dans un cv c'est la condition de
l'autonomie cette génération va être
très pénalisés dans sa recherche
d'emploi de stage d'alternance ne lui
infligeons pas une difficulté de plus en
retard dans le permis de conduire merci
chers collègues la parole est à monsieur
christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs et député monsieur le
député marc le fur le combat contre les
assignations à résidence que trop
souvent notre jeunesse peut connaître
implique effectivement que nous fassions
tout pour qu'elle puisse accès avoir
accès au permis de conduire parce que
nous savons combien cela est
indispensable et la situation que vous
décrivez est réel monsieur le député
nous connaissons de vraie difficulté
c'est injuste injuste pour les jeunes
évidemment injuste aussi pour les
organisations professionnelles et des
professionnels eux mêmes parce qu'ils
ont travaillé en amont pour préparer la
sortie du confinement pour faire face à
l'épidémie et faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent accompagner le plus grand
nombre possible d'élèves qui doivent
passer le permis de conduire et vous
l'avez dit de nombreux examens ont du
être décalées
ce qui fait que nous connaissons une
situation de tension particulière sur
ces sujets nous avons pris et je prends
un certain nombre des décisions et
d'engagement devant vous temps je sais
l'importance du permis de conduire
la première je souhaite vous dire que
nous avons souhaité mobiliser tous les
inspecteurs et que je souhaite aussi
rappeler les inspecteurs qui était
encore en activité il ya moins de deux
ans pour renforcer les effectifs pour
l'examen de la même façon une enveloppe
de 20 mille vingt mille examens
supplémentaires est en cours de
programmation pour juin juillet août
pour faire en sorte que nous puissions
là encore renforcer les capacité
d'offrir l'accès au permis de conduire
8000 créneaux ont d'ores et déjà été
réservés sur ce sujet mais nous devons
aller plus loin pour rattraper le retard
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite abondé très largement
l'enveloppent des permis disponibles et
des créneaux disponibles avec la
possibilité de créer 70 mille places
supplémentaires d'examens afin d' éviter
l'allongement des délais d'attentes que
vous avez évoquées j'ai également
demandé que ces examens supplémentaires
puissent se passer non seulement le
samedi mais aussi le soir en fin de
journée l'ensemble de ces mesures
permettra d'augmenter significativement
le nombre de candidats qui pourront
passer l'examen
et je sais pouvoir compter sur la totale
mobilisation de l'ensemble du corps des
inspecteurs du permis de conduire pour
rattraper ce retard mais vous avez
raison monsieur le député il ne faut
rien laisser passer tant l'accès au
permis de conduire est essentiel pour
notre jeunesse notamment merci monsieur
l'huissier député élie merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre j'ai bien
à noter les réponses que vous avez bien
voulu me formule est maintenant il faut
aller vite très vite et nous serons tous
ici présents comptable est très soucieux
de constater ou de ne pas constater les
mesures que vous avez prises nous sont
très exigeants parce que notre jeunesse
a droit cela on n'a pas le droit
d'abandonner toute une génération
quand on est en train de faire
actuellement merci monsieur le fur la
parole est à monsieur belkhir belhaddad
oui merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des sports allons droit au but
depuis trois mois je rencontre des
sportifs et j'échange avec les clubs les
fédérations les responsables
d'équipement les organisateurs
d'événements et les élus locaux
ils espèrent tous ardemment reprendre
leur activité physique leurs passions
madame la ministre je reste confiant sur
notre capacité à assouplir les
contraintes sanitaires
pour permettre à chacun de pratiquer son
loisir en toute sécurité et rapidement
mais le sport français amateurs et
professionnels a profondément souffert
de cette épidémie du coran navires us
l'arrêt du championnat l'annulation des
compétitions ont occasionné des
difficultés financières pour les clubs
je vous avait alerté sur ce point par
courrier les finances sont fragiles
nous nous montons pas elles sont même
catastrophique pour certains clubs
les divisions sont profondes notamment
entre le sport amateur et le sport
professionnel
madame la ministre quel accompagnement
notamment financiers comptez-vous mettre
en place pour les clubs amateurs en
marathonien des sables que je suis je
sais qu'il faudra à la fois du souffle
de l'endurance et de l'humilité pour
tirer les enseignements profond de cette
crise du comique 19 pour renouveler
notre modèle en réunissant à la même
table les différents acteurs du sport
autour d'un même objectif pour imaginer
un plan de relance inédit pour le sport
soutenu avec force par l'état comme le
sont d'ailleurs d'autres activités en
difficulté pour garantir enfin
redémarrage rapide des compétitions
professionnelles et amateurs pour que
nous puissions vivre nos passions dans
les stades et devant nos télés osant une
échappée dans le dernier kilomètre pour
remporter l'étape avec panache à la
française
pouvez vous madame la ministre nous
informer de vos attentions
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
l'apport l'auto madame roxana
maracineanu ministre des sports monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur belkhir belhaddad chers députés
oui vous avez raison le mouvement
sportif a subi la crise de plein fouet
nous avons tout fait ce gouvernement a
tout fait pour soutenir le sport à tous
les étages un soutien économique un
soutien de l'emploi et à chaque phase du
retour progressif à la normale les
décisions du gouvernement ont concerné
le sport et la santé des pratiquants
avant tout mais les clubs et les
structures privées sont inquiètes vous
raison sur les moyens financiers et sur
l'engagement des français à se
réinscrire à la rentrée c'est pourquoi
dès ce jeudi l' agence nationale du
sport réunira ses membres pour arbitrer
la création d'un fonds de soutien
d'urgence d'un fonds de solidarité
travailler avec les collectivités
mais nous devons aller au-delà du soin
et organiser la relance la relance du
sport en france cette crise a renforcé
mes convictions
celle du rôle que le sport doit jouer en
matière de santé publique d'éducation et
comme un amortisseur social la relance
passera par un soutien à la demande du
sport pour les gens qui veulent agir sur
leur santé et pour les personnes en
difficulté financière la relance du
sport passera par plus de sport aux âges
de l'école maternelle et à l'école
primaire par la prise en charge plus
systématique des français en situation
de handicap est sujet aux maladies
chroniques et je sais que c'est votre
priorité
monsieur le député la relance passera
aussi par une transformation de l'offre
sportive plus adaptée aux besoins des
pratiquants et des territoires
l'état doit continuer ses efforts pour
le développement économique du sport sur
la partie digitalisation transformation
numérique transition écologique
ce plan de relance du sport nous devons
le bâtir ensemble nous le préparons avec
les partenaires il est indispensable et
vital
nous devons organiser un pacte d'union
nationale des acteurs du sport dans la
perspective de la rentrée de septembre
aujourd'hui c'est en marche et soyez sûr
que nous serons au rendez vous merci
merci madame la ministre
la parole à madame marie-christine
dalloz
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
voit si le troisième projet de loi de
finances rectificative tout mais tous
les indicateurs macroéconomiques sont
dans le rouge
par rapport au produit intérieur brut
prévision de déficit à 11 4%
la dette explose littéralement à 121%
les perspectives à venir sont
particulièrement inquiétantes avec la
menace de faillite en cascade et du
retour un chômage de masse la relance
économique est un impératif et nous
devons entamer une course contre la
montre pour accélérer la reprise
le soutien massif à l'emploi doit rester
la priorité absolue de votre
gouvernement
de nombreux secteurs d'activité ont été
et sont lourdement
impacté malheureusement les annulations
de charge envisagée dans ce projet de
loi de finances rectificative sont trop
faibles pour sauver les pme et les tpe
fortement impacté par le confinement
le gouvernement ne propose qu'une
annulation des seules charges sociales
alors que nous nous réclamons également
les exonérations de charges fiscales
les demandes de report de charge dépasse
les 30 milliards d'euros au niveau
national les annulations de charges
proposé par ce plfr sont de 3 milliards
30 milliards d'un côté trois milliards
de l'autre 10%
nous les républicains nous proposons un
plan dette globale qui adapte le soutien
de l'état en fonction de la perte du
chiffre d'affaires le gouvernement a
opté pour une réponse secteur par
secteur mais voulait c'est précisément
de ça de côté un certain nombre d'entre
eux monsieur le premier ministre le
bateau tangue à vous d'affronter la
tempête est de redresser la barre un
plein soutien
oui à quand un plan de relance merci
schaaf allègue la parole à monsieur
gérald darmanin ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics
le seul président même si messieurs les
députés mal à débuter dalloz votre
question porte suffisamment sur
l'annulation de charge
vous avez vous-même souligné le fait que
le gouvernement à la demande du premier
ministre annule les charges patronales
et social pour les secteurs annoncé par
le président de la république reporte
jusqu'à 36 mois l'intégralité des
charges sociales des entreprises qui ne
souhaitent annuler au cas par cas les
charges patronales et sociale en cas de
difficulté et le plfr 3 vous l'avez vu à
des dispositions en effet qui prévoit
l'annulation par le parlement de sa
disposition et qui renvoient à des
crises dont discuteront l'augmentant à
parler aux commissions des secteurs
touchés vous parler d'annulation des
charges fiscales des impôts en somme
madame la députée permettez moi de vous
dire que nous nous rejoignons une
entreprise ne paye aujourd'hui pendant
la crise économique qu'elle a vécu que
la tva et el pais la tva que si elle a
fait du chiffre d'affaires on ne prend
pas la tva dont on est collector lorsqu
on ne travaille pas dans une entreprise
de restaurants qui sont restés fermés ne
paye pas la tva puisque il ne collectait
pas à cette tva nous payer l'impôt sur
les sociétés qu'à partir du moment où on
fait de la valeur ajoutée vous faites du
chiffre d'affaires et des bénéfices
sinon vous ne payez pas cet impôt les
quelques impôts qui reste madame la
députée cd impôts des collectivités
locales nous nous étonnons d'ailleurs
que les associations d'élus qui en
général sont d'autres partis politiques
refusent d'en revenir sur les impros
production qui grèvent d'une grande
partie une grande partie des locaux
alors oui nous avons des dispositions
pour les impôts de production c'est le
cas nous l'avons ouvert pour la cfe qui
rejoint d'ailleurs une idée qu'avait le
président woerth dans le plfr numéro
deux dans le cadre du plan de relance
qu'évoque le président a répliqué le
premier ministre qui sera bientôt
présenté à la nation il y aura également
des baisses d'impôts que travail bruno
le maire et l'ensemble du gouvernement
un petit peu de patience vous avez voté
les deux premiers plfr je suis sûr que
vous voterez le troisième et à la fin
vous risquez de vote et 4e merci
monsieur le ministre
madame le député oui merci monsieur le
ministre vous oubliez une chose c'est
que la situation de la france dans
laquelle nous étions pour aborder cette
crise était la plus défavorable d'europe
en matière de dette en matière de
déficit
et c'est ça notre problème aujourd'hui
on n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
mettre un vrai plan de relance
et c'est votre problème 10% seulement
des reports en annulations
ce n'est pas suffisant merci monsieur le
ministre je ne vous ferai pas l'injure
je pense que c'est pas l'objet je crois
la la concorde nationale que représente
la réplique d'évoquer les chiffres des
comptes publics auquel nous avons trouvé
le pays madame dalloz
mais aujourd'hui la france emprunte à
des taux négatifs elles financent elles
protègent elles financent et protège les
français et ne vous inquiétez pas le
plan de relance sera parmi les plus
ambitieux de tous les pays occidentaux
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame delphine batho chers collègues la
jeune couple est en écoute dans le
bateau la france n'a plus le temps de
tergiverser et contrairement à ce qu'a
répondu le premier ministre tout à
l'heure la vocation de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat n'est pas de
susciter des débats mais que des
décisions soient prises
hier il faisait 38 degrés en sibérie
l'année dernière il a fait 46 dans
l'hérault on nous annonce de nouvelle
canicule la vérité chers collègues c'est
que ce que dit la science c'est que le
changement climatique est désormais une
question de sécurité nationale et que
nous ne sommes pas à l'abri de
phénomènes d'emballement
alors oui merci aux 150 citoyennes et
citoyens de leurs propositions qui
montrent que répondre à cet impératif de
sécurité
c'est changer nos modes de vie
le gouvernement le parlement sont
maintenant face à leurs responsabilités
et le groupe écologie démocratie
solidarité fait une proposition très
simple inscrivons à l'ordre du jour au
mois de juillet un projet donnant force
de loi aux 149 propositions nous sommes
prêts et
nous sommes prêts à y travailler tout
l'été une seule chose compte l'urgence
des résultats l'urgence de faire il ya
une grande différence entre la
convention citoyenne pour le climat et
tous les processus qui ont existé dans
le passé
cette différence c'est qu'il existe
aujourd'hui dans la société un mouvement
social culturel et politique pour
l'écologie un mouvement de la jeunesse
dont les mobilisations ne s'arrêteront
pas le gouvernement est devant un choix
historique soit relancé investir réparer
à coups de milliards dans un modèle
destructeur et consumériste soit
réinventer un modèle français résilient
respectueux de l'humain relocalisant
notre économie c'est l'un ou l'autre
quel choix fera le gouvernement est ce
qu'il choisira l'écologie ou est-ce
qu'il choisira de faire barrage à la
convention si c'est pas la norme c'est
fini donc la parole est à madame
elisabeth bornes ministre la transition
écologique et solidaire
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
delphine batho
je vous remercie de saluer le travail
des 150 femmes et hommes qui ont
travaillé d'arrache-pied pendant neuf
mois pour nous faire une proposition
globale pour accélérer la transition
écologique et solidaire indirectement je
vous remercie salué l'initiative prise
par le président de la république à la
fin du débat national du grand débat
national pour répondre à une attente
forte qui s'était exprimé dans ce débat
plus de démocratie et plus d'écologie
moi j'ai noté je voudrais vous le redire
que les citoyens ont pu s'appuyer
ils me l'ont dit j'imagine qu'il voulons
dit sur les textes de loi adopté depuis
le début du quinquennat
je pense à la loi sur les hydrocarbures
à la loi mobilité à la loi énergie
climat à la loi anti gaspillage pour une
économie circulaire et je pense qu'on
peut être fier que la cette majorité
peut être fier d'avoir porté ses
propositions d'avoir protesté ces textes
alors que nous disent les citoyens ils
nous disent que les échanges qu'ils ont
eus avec les experts avec les
scientifiques leur ont fait prendre
conscience de la nécessité d'aller plus
vite ou plus loin et c'est bien le sens
des propositions qu'ils nous ont remises
certaines propositions vous le savez
sont aboutis et elles pourront donc être
transmises sans filtre comme le
président s'y était engagée pour que le
débat se poursuivre l'élaboration des
textes se poursuivent dans cette
assemblée
d'autres je crois que c'est à peu près
les deux tiers mérite encore un travail
mais vous pouvez évidemment compter sur
le gouvernement pour poursuivre ce
travail et pour aller au bout de cette
démarche comme les citoyens l'attend je
remercie merci madame la ministre la
parole à madame sabine rubin merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur
ce gouvernement je le caractérise d'un
mot la police partout la justice nulle
part
cette sentence est celle d'un homme dont
personne ici de doute de l'attachement à
la république et à ses valeurs
victor hugo tous ici en convenons la
police républicaine est une institution
qui doit garantir la paix publics
essentiels au fonctionnement de la cité
elle ne saurait souffrir d'aucun
manquement d'aucune outrance et ne
devrait pas être l'instrument aveugle
d'une répression disproportionnée et
parfois meurtrières le 3 janvier dernier
cédric joue via un livreur de 42 ans
mourait pourtant d'un malaise cardiaque
des suites d'une interpellation
policière
j'étouffe j'étouffe voilà ses dernières
paroles plaquage ventrale étranglement
technique barbare dont vous vous étiez
alors ému à juste titre promettant des
changements depuis c'est la pression de
l'opinion publique la multiplication des
affaires qui vous oblige à vous remettre
à l'ouvragé mais la réponse des éléments
les plus réactionnaires de la police
nationale ne s'est pas fait attendre
le syndicat alliance pour ne nommer que
lui encouragent les provocations
hier soir à proximité de cette enceinte
des policiers en armes manifestèrent en
toute illégalité
et cela alors même que votre
gouvernement poursuit le confinement de
la protestation sociale
multipliant les interdits autour des
manifestations à stains les policiers
exige le censurer une oeuvre d'art
monsieur le ministre vous nous trouverez
toujours aux côtés des policiers pour
appuyer leurs revendications en matière
de salaires de formation de moyens
humains et de logistique supplémentaire
mais nous serons aussi toujours du côté
de la république pour défendre le droit
de nos concitoyens face aux exactions
d'une poignée de factieux vous êtes
aujourd'hui au milieu du gué soyez enfin
république à monsieur castaner ne restez
pas sous l'emprise de syndicats mer et
condamné fermement ces agissements fait
parole que monsieur christophe castaner
ministre de l'intérieur merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs et
madame la députée je crois que
parlementaire ministre en tant que
dépositaire de la puissance publique des
élus de la république
justement doivent se montrer à la
hauteur de ce que les forces de l'ordre
font au quotidien pour assurer la
sécurité de tous nos administrés de tous
nos concitoyens de tous les français
madame la députée vous évoquez cette
fresque à stains cette fresque elle me
choque
elle me choque parce que et je partage
l'indignation de celles et ceux qui
trouvent qu'il est totalement scandaleux
de faire un amalgame et d'inaugurer en
écharpe train bleu blanc rouge
une fresque qui vise à faire d amalgame
et qui vise à faire en sorte de montrer
que la police serait par nature violente
nos madame la députée il n'y a pas en
république de violences illégitimes
portés par nos forces de sécurité
intérieure il y a chaque jour des femmes
des hommes qui se mobilisent et qui font
en sorte de protéger la république et
ils sont légitimes à utiliser la force
ne fait pas cet amalgame mais elle doit
être utilisée de façon proportionnée de
façon adaptée de façon adéquate et nous
devons veiller à leur formation aux
techniques qu'ils utilisent et à faire
en sorte que s'il ya faute il y ait
instruction il y en quête ailier
sanctions c'est cela madame la députée
la république
vous avez évoqué le décès de cédric
souviens j'avais dans les jours qui ont
suivi son décès reçu sa famille
j'avais partagé avec eux cette émotion
bien légitime de l'ensemble de la nation
sur ce qui s'est passé et j'ai fait en
sorte de prendre des engagements
j'ai immédiatement saisi le directeur
général de la police nationale et de la
gendarmerie nationale avec laurent nunez
ils nous ont rendu un rapport sur
l'ensemble des techniques qui peuvent
présenter un risque et c'est sur la base
de ces préconisations qu'avec laurent
nunez nous avons pris un certain nombre
de décisions mais madame la députée je
n'appartiens pas au camp de ceux qui
préside votre groupe qui souhaite
désarmés de façon schématique nos forces
de sécurité intérieure nos forces de
sécurité intérieures elles ont besoin
d'être défendue elles ont besoin d'être
protégés merci monsieur le ministre la
parole à madame florence provende y est
à elle seule
merci monsieur le président à ma
question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et la
lutte contre les discriminations
pour la 24ème édition du parlement des
enfants
780 classe de cm2 ont planché sur le
thème de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
j'ai eu l'honneur de présider le jury
national et à ce titre je souhaite
féliciter chacun des élèves
et chacun des professeurs qui se sont
engagés dans cet exercice citoyen
permettez moi d'adresser une mention
spéciale à la classe de canto perdrix de
à martigues
lauréate grâce à une proposition de loi
remarquable sur la mixité dans le sport
en janvier dernier nous votions à
l'unanimité une résolution pour prendre
en compte les droits de l'enfant dans
tous nos travaux parlementaires et
associer les enfants à notre vie
démocratique
en ce sens je me ferai ici leur porte
voix auprès de vous c'est avec beaucoup
de justesse que les auteurs des
propositions de lois du parlement des
enfants
interroge les inégalités les stéréotypes
persistant dans notre société moindre
médiatisation des sports lorsque
pratiqué par des femmes difficulté pour
les femmes d'accéder à certains métiers
inégalités dans le partage des tâches
dans le couple écarts de rémunération à
poste égal quand elles y ont accès dans
un tiers de ses propositions c'est
l'éducation et la sensibilisation qui
ressortent comme les meilleurs leviers
pour faire cesser les injustices par
ailleurs de nombreuses classes ont
proposé l'extension du congé paternité
une façon concrète d'instaurer une
égalité dans le couple parental et de
changer les regards dès 2017
le président de la république a déclaré
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
grande cause du quinquennat et vous
portez madame la ministre
cette bataille avec détermination vous
êtes exprimé régulièrement pour
l'émancipation économique des femmes et
l'extension du congé paternité aussi
pouvez vous nous éclairer sur la façon
dont vous souhaitez concrétiser ses
attentes sociétales formulées par les
enfants je vous remercie
sûr que l'aig la parole comme la
marronne schiappa secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et de la lutte contre les
discriminations
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée florence provence et mesdames et
messieurs les députés d'abord je
souhaite à nouveau félicité en notre nom
à tous les 780 classe d'élèves qui ont
planché sur les questions d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et
particulièrement la classe de cm2 de
martigues qui s'est engagé avec le
parlement des enfants
ces jeunes n'ont pas écouté ce qu'on
leur a dit et j'en suis ravi ils n'ont
pas écouté ceux qui sans cesse répète
que la politique c'est très difficile
que la politique c'est très compliqué et
que la politique ce serait hors de leur
portée
non la politique ce n'est pas trop
difficile ce n'est pas trop compliqué et
ce n'est pas hors de la portée de qui
que ce soit ces jeunes personnes nous
l'ont prouvé et les membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
ont remis leurs propositions à la
ministre elisabeth bornes l'ont prouvé
également nous avons besoin je crois de
cette jeune génération qui est s'y
engager positivement pour le climat pour
l'égalité femmes hommes pour la liberté
tous ceux qui ont la chance d'avoir des
enfants ou des adolescents à la maison
lesage bien je crois que avec eux nous
ferons des inégalités une histoire du
passé
ces enfants ont plébiscité l'allongement
du congé paternité comme l'avait fait
d'ailleurs les membres de la grande
consultation pour l'émancipation
économique des femmes alors oui je vous
le dis le gouvernement d'edouard
philippe allongera le congé paternité et
collectivement avec l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement
nous y travaillons je sais que cette
volonté est partagée par de nombreux
membres du parlement sur différents
bancs et je me réjouis que les membres
de la délégation aux droits des femmes
du parlement est d'ores et déjà indiqué
s'emparer de cette question dans la
droite continuité de la grande cause du
quinquennat du président la république
pour l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes dans cette assemblée
considérablement renouvelée rajeunie et
féminisée
et vous en est la démonstration merci
madame la ministre la parole est un
madame nadia ramassamy
merci monsieur le président je tiens à
féliciter les enfants de la classe de
cm2 de l'école antoine berthe et à
sainte suzanne
je suis fier du travail qu'ils ont
accompli sur la lutte contre
l'appartenance des jouets à un genre
ma question s'adresse maintenant à
monsieur le premier ministre la
situation dans les autres mers est grave
si la plupart des territoires
ultramarins ont été placées en zone
verte à l'exception de la guyane de
mayotte des restrictions de déplacement
continue à mener la vie dure au tourisme
bien sûr la limitation des déplacements
a été nécessaire lorsque nous étions
coeur de l'épidémie
on nous a répété que les français
pourraient se rendre en outre mer cet
été hors nous sommes en été le verre de
l'hexagone serait-il plus vert que celui
des outre mer je ne l'espère pas
le tourisme est vitale et ces mesures
l'asphyxient la situation économique
dans les autres mers déjà difficile
s'est dégradé plus que dans le reste de
la france
l'épidémie révèlent les carences de nos
infrastructures sanitaires
nous payons une fois de plus l'inaction
du gouvernement nous ne voulons pas de
fausses mesures comme c'est le cas avec
le fonds exceptionnel d'investissement
qui n'a dé sectionnelles que le nom
puisqu'il est alloué chaque année vous
vous êtes contentés de le verser en
avance nos commerçants agriculteurs
hôteliers restaurateurs acteurs du
bâtiment et du logement pâtissent tous
de la crise sanitaire et les mesures
censées les aider tarder à arriver
cela révèle encore une fois le manque
d'intérêt que le gouvernement nous porte
nous travaillons nous payons des impôts
nous ne sommes pas les danseuses de la
république
nous sommes en 2020 et le ministère d
outre-mer peine encore à intégrer la
transe oui la france et outre-mer ne
sont ni moins français que l'hexagone ni
des territoires de seconde zone
merci
merci madame la députée la parole comme
chevry attaqué secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre des solidarités de la santé
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés les outre-mer deux côtés dans
cette lutte contre la crise du coc vide
permettez moi d'ailleurs d'excuser
l'absence dany gérardin mais qui
justement se trouve dans les outre mer
elle était hier à saint martin et elle
se trouve aujourd'hui en guyane dont
vous savez vous l'avez pensionnés
la situation reste compliquée doit être
sous surveillance
si l'épidémie décroît à mayotte
toujours sous surveillance elle est
encore dans une la guyane est encore
dans une situation compliquée alors que
s'agissant peut-être at-il trop mais a
peut-être de la réunion plus
particulièrement quelques données
sanitaires pour vous dire que la
circulation du virus reste faible on
enregistrait 507 chaos total
depuis l'apparition du premier cas le 11
mars dernier plus de 3800 personnes sont
appelées individuellement et sont suivis
dans le cadre du contact racing dont
vous voyez cette stratégie de détection
traçage d'isolement s'applique aussi
évidemment à l'outre-mer outre-mer qui
comme à la réunion est aussi frappé par
une épidémie de dengue vous le savez
madame et qui représente une véritable
menace sanitaire pour nos pour nos
concitoyens
alors vous avez parlé des mesures de
restriction de circulation madame la
députée depuis le 9 juin les voyageurs
entrant sur le territoire qui ont
réalisé un test que 8,19 doivent au
maximum au maximum 72 heures avant leur
embarquement peuvent bénéficier d'un
dispositif d'isolement alléger c'est le
cas de votre territoire madame la
députée ses passagers sont soumis à un
isolement strict de sept jours suivie
d'un nouveau test puis d'une seconde
période de sept jours et pour les
passagers qui n'ont pas réalisé de test
un isolement strict de 14 jours est
maintenu depuis hier la députée
le nombre de passagers autorisés sur
chaque vol et dé plafonner le nombre de
vols hebdomadaires à destination de la
réunion par exemple va progressivement
augmentée permettant aux territoires
d'exploiter pleinement sa capacité au
touristique et à 14 vols d'ores et déjà
qu'ils sont programmées cette semaine et
il ne sera plus nécessaire de justifier
d'un motif impérieux
pour se déplacer entre la métropole et
la réunion tests obligatoires
mais la 40e mais je suis rimer buts et
20 secondes pour 20 secondes
déjà je pense qu'il répond à côté j'ai
pas posé seins comme question d'abord un
donc en fait il faut pas noyer le
poisson déjà ensuite je tiens à dire que
le fonds devait à l'origine s'élever à
500 millions mais il n'est que de 110
millions aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas un cadeau que vous nous
faites quand les outre-mer faut arrêter
de raconter
merci madame le député à paroles que
monsieur j villepin
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame elisabeth bornes
madame la ministre aux assises de la mer
en décembre dernier le président de la
république avait déclaré que le 21e
siècle serait maritime
il avait ce jour-là présenté les quatre
grands axes de la stratégie maritime
française soutient la recherche
protection de la biodiversité
développement d'une économie bleue et
défense de nos intérêts géostratégiques
en outre-mer la semaine dernière le
président a ajouté vouloir accélérer la
mise en oeuvre de cette stratégie dans
le cadre de la reprise économique
des mots qui ont retenu toute
l'attention de la communauté maritime
française que le président de la
république évoque le potentiel maritime
de la france dans une adresse solennelle
à la nation
le symbole est fort dans ce domaine
comme dans les autres
la crise a mis en lumière nos atouts et
nos faiblesses elle a notamment mis en
lumière le besoin de penser différemment
le transport maritime de le penser dans
sa dimension stratégique et pas
uniquement commercial pour faire sienne
une logique de souveraineté de
compétitivité au bénéfice de la
transition écologique de l'emploi et du
savoir-faire des français je voudrais en
profiter pour tous remercié les marranes
commerce
les pêcheurs qui continue à assurer
l'approvisionnement de la france pendant
cette crise sanitaire
notre surface maritime notre communauté
scientifique et nos secteurs économiques
d'excellence nous confère une
responsabilité particulière au sein de
notre communauté internationale celle
d'être à l'avant garde de la lutte
contre le changement climatique et la
préservation de la biodiversité marine
dans les négociations sur la hausse
mr à l'onu et lors du prochain congrès
de l'uci henan a marseille deux fêtes du
transport maritime à la course au large
de notre école de voile en passant par
la pêche et l'industrie nautique et les
énergies marines renouvelables
le monde maritime vit une révolution
permanente depuis quelques années madame
la ministre
comment concrètement accélérer la mise
en oeuvre de la stratégie maritime
française et la faire évoluer pour
prendre en compte les notions apprises
dans la crise merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le député la parole est à
madame elisabeth bornes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jimmy pahun vous rappeler à juste titre
l'ambition de la stratégie maritime
porté par le président de la république
et le gouvernement
et comme vous l'avez fait je voudrais à
mon tour salué la mobilisation des
acteurs du secteur des élus des ong
pendant la crise le gouvernement a été à
leurs côtés pour leur apporter des aides
d'urgence les accompagner au plan
sanitaire
mais vous le savez aussi pour les
assister pour le rapatriement des marins
qui pouvait parfois être bloquée à
l'autre bout du monde
j'ai changé encore récemment avec le
conseil national de la mer et des
littoraux et j'ai noté leurs attentes
fortes pour l'avenir
aussi je vous le confirme notre
stratégie maritime est au coeur de
l'engagement que le président de la
république a pris pour reconstruire une
économie forte écologique souveraine et
solidaire suite aux échanges que j'ai pu
avoir j'identifie trois grandes
priorités accélérer la décarbonation en
accompagnant le verdissement des
transports maritimes et des ports mais
aussi en accélérant le déploiement des
énergies marines renouvelables accroître
la résilience de notre territoire par la
bonne gestion de nos écosystèmes et de
nos littoraux face aux risques miser sur
l'innovation notamment pour accompagner
les projets d'éco conception et de
recyclage des entreprises navale et
nautiques
par ailleurs l'économie maritime c'est
aussi le tourisme et son développement
durable nous travaillerons avec les
acteurs pour une déclinaison dans ce
sens du plan tourisme
le travail se poursuit au sein du
conseil national de la mer et des
littoraux que je réunirai à nouveau mi
juillet donc vous l'aurez compris
monsieur le député je suis convaincu que
la sortie de crise sera l'occasion de
conforter encore notre stratégie
maritime jean merci merci madame la
ministre que la parole est à monsieur
dominique potier merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre il faut arrêter d'être
naïf s'étirer breton commissaire au
marché intérieur qui lance cet appel il
faut arrêter d'être naïf d'aucuns
disaient avant il faut pour l'europe
cessé d'être un peu l'idiot utile de la
mondialisation
il va savoir falloir protéger nos actifs
stratégiques dans l'industrie le sujet
n'est pas nouveau depuis une décennie
depuis 2010 c'est de 5000 à 28000
entreprises qui sont passés sous
contrôle asiatiques d'hiver mais
essentiellement chinois avec souvent des
participations de l'état de complexe
militaro industriel
le sujet n'est pas nouveau mais il prend
un relief particulière dans la crise du
que vides au moment où on s'inquiète
avait un lien à cognac pour nokia
à lannion le risque est grand de voir
des drames humains des plans sociaux des
crises territoriales bref une question
humaine surgir mais également la
question de l'autonomie stratégique pour
ne pas dire souveraineté de notre europe
de notre pays
quand on parle d' actifs stratégiques
j'ai envie d'évoquer un des grands
sujets qui sera celui du green deal
européen est je l'espère nous l'espérons
socialiste du plan de relance français
la lutte contre le gaspillage de l'eau
dans l'eau potable sécurisation adapter
au changement climatique lutte contre le
gaspillage d'un litre sur cinq dans nos
réseaux d'eau potable aujourd'hui
sécurité en matière de technologie le
transport de l'eau jusqu'à l'industrie
nucléaire et pour l'énergie alimentarité
la question de l'eau potable la question
de les conducteurs d'eau potable sont
une question stratégique pour demain
hors pam saint gobain la filiale du
groupe saint-gobain aujourd'hui envisage
des alliances y compris capitalistique
qui pourrait faire perdre sa
souveraineté
économique sur le marché de l'eau qui
représente 10 % 10 % du marché monde qui
représente 50% du marché européen 80% du
marché français thierry breton comment
pouvons-nous traduire concrètement son
appel en matière de réciprocité
commerciale de protection des actifs de
nouvelle gouvernance de capacité à
réformer le droit moindre bref c'est à
nous à nous armer pour que l'europe soit
une puissance et cesse d'abandonner ses
actifs physiques avec la parole était
madame agnès pannier winch et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances
merci monsieur le président monsieur
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député potier d'abord je
veux répondre très rapidement aux points
que vous avez rapidement mentionné sur
l'accord commercial qu'auraient conclu
saint gobain avec reese à eau qui est
une entreprise chinoise
je veux dire ici très précisément que
cet accord ne comporte aucun transfert
technologique qu'il ne couvre que le
marché chinois sur des références que
pam pont-à-mousson ne fabrique pas et
que saint gobain a très clairement
établi dans un communiqué de presse
publié le 10 juin à notre demande pour
faire enlever toute ambiguïté que en
tout état de cause ce partenaire n'était
pas considéré pour le devenir de ponte à
montceau pour élargir le propos vous
avez raison pour un bouchon c'est
l'accès à une matière première précieuse
l'eau avec des réseaux d'eau qui
aujourd'hui ont des taux de déperdition
de l'ordre de 20 de l'ordre de 20%
donc il ya un vrai enjeu à préserver
cette des partitions d'une matière
première qui va devenir de plus en plus
précieuse et que les conduites et la
spécialité de pont-à-mousson devrait
permettre avec des tubes qui sont
extrêmement durable de prévenir dans les
années qui viennent mais ça veut dire un
accès à des marchés publics à des
conditions qui soient compétitives par
rapport à une concurrence qui peut
apparaître déloyale et vous l'avez dit
thierry breton a parlé de l'air de
l'europe naïve est révolue mais je crois
qu'il a repris assez largement tous les
propos et toutes les
la défense que nous avons eues ces
derniers mois pour justement porté cette
vision au plan européen
lorsque l'on parle de règles de
réciprocité pour l'accès aux marchés
publics par exemple lorsque l'on parle
d'un mécanisme d'inclusion carbone aux
frontières
lorsque l'on parle du renforcement du
contrôle des investissements étrangers
vous savez que nous l'avons renforcé en
france et que ce modèle est aujourd'hui
repris au plan européen
lorsque l'on parle de l'adaptation du
droit de la concurrence ou de la
taxation minimale des plateformes
numériques sur lesquels nous travaillons
et nous sommes proactifs au niveau
français la séance des questions au
gouvernement est terminée prochaines
séances de mach 1 0 possession de loi
créant la fonction de directeur d'école
la séance est levée